So, Leute, fertig essen, dann können wir eine Runde leveln.
Fuck, ich wollte gerade mal kurz gucken, ob ich gescheite Chest finde für später.
Wie hieß das Ding? Reflect? Wie hieß der Kram? Ich habe den Mod vergessen.
Ja, good luck, have fun. Wie hieß der Kram? Reflect, dass man immun gegen Reflect ist.
Ah, ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt.
Erst mal mein Path of Building aufmachen. Leute, das wird jetzt nach dem Morgen streamen,
das wird jetzt eine ganz entspannte Geschichte. Wir leveln jetzt, was auch immer, wie lange das
dauert, bis Endgame durch. Cock Items. Was empfiehlt der Typ hier nochmal? Ach, genau,
das war das. By the way, das will ich überhaupt nicht haben. Chaos Bellslinger, das klingt gut.
Ja, genau. Ja, sehr gut. Und das jetzt mal gucken, ob wir das irgendwie kombinieren,
was da so die Chests kosten. Megateuer. Und außerdem sacken die restlichen
Stats auch nochmal Hardcore. Das ist schön teuer, der Kram. Chaos Resists, nice. Naja,
ich muss sagen, auf geht's. Ich muss erst mal verdauen jetzt. Ein riesen Potnudel gefuttert.
Und ich muss mal mein Memeboard starten. Riesen Potnudel gefuttert. Eigentlich bin ich jetzt im
Halbschlaf. Nee, Teinsa schon wieder on. Der Aufwachstream ist vorbei. Woher soll man denn
10 Exhauls herbekommen? Das geht. Exzellent. Einfach haben vorher z.B. Seeds verkaufen. Das
geht diese... Sebaru, ich war doch bis vor 20 Minuten on. Mit Aufwachstream. Oder vor einer
halben Stunde oder so. Ja, guck hier. Warum höre ich mich jetzt doppelt? Das neue Twitch,
das ist so eklig. Also ich weiß nicht, was sie sich hiermit gedacht haben. Vor allem,
dass man immer da draufklicken muss, damit man dann hier das kriegt. Ganz, ganz merkwürdig.
Nee, guck hier. Aufwachstream und das letzte Kommen. Wann, wie viel Uhr war das? 3 Uhr
einfach. Nee, Moment, das geht ja nicht mal. Also 4 Stunden, vor 5 Stunden habe ich angefangen.
Also vor knapp einer Stunde oder irgendwie 40, 45 Minuten bin ich aufgegangen. Gears 5,
was läuft denn da? Gears Esport Final. Was nicht alles gibt. Lull. Du hast den Aufwachstream
verpasst. Morgen KS. Kannst ja, wenn du willst, das Wort angucken. Aber ansonsten, ich bin
morgen noch mal on. Wie gesagt, ich habe ja morgen frei, wie immer. Und morgen machen
wir wieder ein bisschen Raspberry Pi gebasteln. Du hast dir eine OK Sim bestellt. Das lohnt
sich. Echt? Ich muss mal kurz meine Microtransactions checken. Die sehen kacke aus. Hopp. Keine Flügel
und Umhang. Okay, das sieht schon besser aus. Echt, das lohnt sich, hätte ich gar nicht
gedacht. So, schau mal, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben? Anfang, Anfang, Akt 5. Gut, weiter
geht's. Boah, keine Ahnung, irgendwas. Brauchen wir nichts, gescheit. Aber die Ringe, die
wir haben, sind mega crap. Ob da irgendwas gescheit bei ist. Hopp. Hyper crap, Alter.
Wobei, warte mal. Hyper crap. Hallo, Destroy. Oh, es war ein Stash. Bin so selten in der
Base. Spell Damage. Ah, das hat Lightning, okay. Der ist ganz gut. Ist nämlich gestern
schon angezogen. Guck mal, der hat krasse Resists, der Ring, der ist ziemlich nice.
So, erstmal hier Awakening Trade starten. Gears 5 E-Sport, ist das dann so toll wie
die Overwatch E-Sport? Ich glaube, das ist noch mehr Nische als Overwatch E-Sport. Spätestens
seit Blizzard der Meinung war, wir gehen jetzt auf YouTube, ist eh vorbei mit Overwatch E-Sport.
So, auf geht's, zack. Alle NPCs beschwätzt. Irgendwo gab's hier was. Okay, auf geht's.
Bashed. Ich bin ultra müde jetzt da am futtern. So, was mussten wir hier jetzt machen? Ich
muss mal laut denken. Genau, wir mussten hier das eine Quest-Item holen. Eigentlich können
wir hier durchrushen. Wir haben eh schon viel zu nice Gear, viel zu nice Speck, viel zu
nice Level. Na gut, Level. Aber Level brauchen wir hier nicht. Im nächsten Gebiet ist das
viel besser. Genau, wir mussten hier so ein Item holen und dann mussten wir hoch zum Square
raus. Ich muss mal laut denken. Ich hab mir zwar einen Guide aufgeschrieben, mal vor
einer Weile so für mich, dass ich Sachen in der Kampagne nicht vergesse, wenn ich mal
wieder einen Char durchschleusen muss, aber manchmal muss ich mal ein bisschen laut vor
mich hin denken, dass ich nix vergesse. So, irgendwo hier unten ist da Kram immer. Ah,
da ist es doch. Oh ja, Vorgas. Hallo, lass mich hier durch. Warum darf ich hier nicht
durch? Geht doch. Genau, das komische Item hier holen und dann... Ah, G-Baded, hier
geht es nicht rauf. Und dann rauf, raus hier aus dem Gebiet. Das ist so geil, das macht
so Damage, Alter. Du bashst hier einfach alles weg mit zwei Spells. Guck mal hier, der macht
nix. Einfach mal hier durch flitzen. Speedrun-Stretz. Okay, dann müssen wir noch richtig laufen.
Nee, euer Ernst, hier ist nix. Hoffentlich gebaden mich die Maps nicht wieder so wie gestern
die eine Map. Das ist sie. You got G-Baded. G-Bade, genau. Normalerweise ist das relativ
schwer, man muss einfach nach oben rennen und dann kommt man direkt raus. Aber wir machen
so krass Damage. Richtig Pog. Hier kann es doch gar nicht weitergehen, oder? Muss man
echt wieder komplett vor. Also, der Damage ist so krank. Vor allem mit ein bisschen nur
Minimal Gear. Also recht günstig, aber what the hell. Jetzt kann man hier nicht irgendwie
durch. Das ist nicht euer Ernst, oder? Game, please. Darf man hier irgendwo durch? Ich
will hier hoch. Game, lass mich hoch. Hier, bam. Schreckt, outplayed. Deswegen immer,
immer Flame Dash. Boah, ich bin jetzt echt müde nach dem Essen, the fuck. Wir haben langsam
Zeit fürs Bett, oder? So, jetzt sind wir hier gleich raus. 14.40 Uhr kann man schon mal
pennen gehen. Die Map wegmachen, ne. Das ist wie in Diablo 2, da hast du auch immer mit
der Map über dem Kopf gespielt. Ich muss euch was beichten, Chat. Diablo 2 war glaube
ich das einzige Multiplayer-Game, wo ich mal gecheatet habe. Diablo 2 hatte ich Maphack
und eigentlich müssen wir jetzt nur nach oben und dann rechts. Band. Oh stimmt, darf
man sowas nicht mehr erzählen. Du hast in CS 1.6 gecheatet. Ne, CS habe ich nie gecheatet.
Diablo aber auch nur, weil es kein PvP-Game ist, mir teilweise die Map-Playouts mega auf
den Kicks gegangen sind. Und ich wollte halt schnellere Magic-Find-Runs machen. Hier geht's
los. Du hast in Mädchen 2 gespielt. Alter Mädchen, das ist auch so ein China-Kreisegrind-Game.
Dann habt ihr bestimmt Runescape oder sowas gespielt, ne? Der Sebaro hat bestimmt Runescape
gespielt. Das passt irgendwie. Oder? Das hast du mal getestet, ok. Den Sinn von Runescape,
also warum das die Leute so geil fanden, habe ich auch nicht ganz nachvollziehen können.
In Runescape hatten die Leute schon Waifus, bevor es das Wort Waifu überhaupt gab. Und
E-Grills. Ich habe es aber auch nie gespielt, ich kann das nur vom Hören sagen. Was gibt
es in PSV nicht zu raffen? Einfach Monster-Baschen. Einfach geradeaus laufen Monster-Baschen und
looten. Easy. Also. Was, der Discord verliert bald einen Boost? Ja gut, kann ich da irgendwas
gegen machen? Oder ist das halt einfach so? Man kann Boost kaufen, habe ich ja nie gemacht.
Und das soll Spaß machen, ja. Übels Pock. Das ist Diablo 3 nur in gut. Davon abgesehen,
dass es eine ganze Weile vor die Diablo 3 gab. 35 pro Jahr pro Boost. Kann ich machen?
Wo kauft man Boost? Ist das so, dass man das in seinem eigenen Account kaufen muss und
dann Server boostet oder kann man das direkt für einen Server kaufen? Discord mehr Geld
kaufen, ja. Twitch-Money muss irgendwo hin, Leute. Komm, ein Monster-Pack noch für Level-Up.
Mob, hat kein Bock. Level-up denied. Oh, jetzt. Keine Ahnung, wer das hat. Ja, ich weiß auch
nicht, wer das sein könnte. Kannst du auf den Server gehen und dann dort für diesen
Server Boost kaufen? Mach ich später. Mach ich später. Einer der nervigsten Bosse im
Spiel, weil er so lange dauert. Man können, tut er ja nix. Der sackt einfach nur. Aber
er dauert so lange, weil er spawn 1000 Erz. Die Erz können auch nix. Die Erz können sterben.
Wie viel Boost braucht man bis Level 1? Ich glaub nur einen, oder? Ich glaub drei für
Level 2. Ich wollte dich eigentlich nicht zum Abo-Suppen, zum Abo-Verschenken debaten gerade.
Oh, danke für den Sub. Wer hat eigentlich gekriegt? Karzalen. Huge. Da war gestern
ganzen Tag schon im PoE-Stream da. Aber ist ja gut. 15 für Level 2, 30 für Level 3.
Ich kauf dann Boost. Irgendwohin muss die Kohle ja gehen und außerdem ist der Discord-Server
ja erstaunlich big brain immer. Da gibt es ja sogar Channels, wo die Leute sich gegenseitig
helfen. Das ist ja was, das kennt man ja so aus dem Internet gar nicht. Also Leute, die
sich freiwillig, ohne dass sie was von haben, helfen. Was ist da los? Das gibt es nur beim
QtChat Discord. Tin Weebspam-Channel? Nein, den meinte ich jetzt so explizit nicht. Wobei
wenn man so will, ja die Leute helfen sich da auch. Können wir jetzt verrecken, please?
Wow. Wie soll das noch mal wissen? Gut, bla bla bla, Zwischensequenz, skip, next. Was
habe ich denn da aufgehoben? Müll. Next. Einfach durchrushen oder an der Kiste hängen bleiben.
Die letzte Mal musste ich immer links rum raus. Gucken ob die Map diesmal, vielleicht
habe ich ja irgendein System in der Map entdeckt. Gucken ob das wieder links rum raus geht. Alter
Tür gehe auf. Das Bild ist so OP zum Leveln, Wahnsinn. Jetzt einfach nur hin und schreckst
es. Die machen ja gar nichts, die können ja gar nichts dagegen machen. Moin. Ja zum
Leveln beste, voll Metaslave als Bild. Setze ihn wieder links raus. Ich glaube ich habe
die Map calculated. Ich war jetzt hier immer Brain Hacker-Mans und dann weiß ich wo es
lang geht auf der Map. Die Map hier ist eine der Maps, die ist überall gleich aufgebaut.
Die hat so gut wie kein random Faktor. Nehme mal Bane mit. Ich habe theoretisch sogar in
dem, ich habe mir so ein simples Passive Building rausgesucht zum Skill. Ich glaube der hat
sogar noch ein paar andere Debuffs dabei. Warte mal, lass mich mal überlegen. Wo ging
es hier? Man musste erstmal in die Mitte. In die Mitte und so ein komisches Viech-Baschen.
Ich bin gerade verwirrt. Ich renne ja auch so schon übelst durch. WTF? Ach da geht es
lang. Konnte man nicht auf die Silver Flask auch draufcraften, dass man durch Gegner durchrennen
kann. So Phasing. Man zeugt halt aktuell gar nichts drauf. Ich kann mich noch erinnern,
man müsste jetzt in die Mitte irgendwie so ein Typ Baschen. Wenn man den Typ gebasht
hat, dann kann man runter unten rechts den Typ killen. Unten rechts in das nächste Gebiet,
aber erstmal muss man in die Mitte den Typ killen. Ich weiß unten rechts geht es weiter,
aber man muss in der Mitte doch noch so ein Typ killen für einen Speck Point oder? Da
war doch was. Quest geht unten weiter, aber irgendwo rechts muss man doch noch irgendeinen
Tut killen. Oder war das nur ein Respec Point? Den braucht man nicht. Hier den da meine ich.
Der ist nur ein Müll Juwel. Ich glaube ein Juwel ist gar nicht schlecht.
Vielleicht ist das sogar das Juwel. Zumindest geht unten rechts weiter. Ich glaube das gibt
auch ein Skill Point hier, wenn man die ganzen Craps sammelt.
Lass mich in Ruhe. Genau, wie viel braucht man? Drei Stück? Vier Stück? Braucht man glaube
ja. Junge nicht die Gegner noch, nö. Das ist absolut OP. Aber ich habe auch recht gutes
Levelgear am Start. Ich habe auch Capped Resies. Oh, ja kann ich mal sterben hier oben. Ich
habe ja auch hier. Brauche ich dich nicht wirklich, weil ich eh nur maximal vier Links
habe. Movement Speed, Resi Kram, plus eins Chaos, plus eins Chaos und random Kram. Also
zum Level ist das ziemlich gut. Äh Moment, habe ich jetzt eigentlich alles? Ich glaube
schon, ja ich habe alles. Dann gehen wir mal kurz zum Waypoint. Gehst du später auf Lore
Life? Äh ich speck später komplett um, äh nicht Hideout. Was will ich im Hideout,
alter? Ich will nicht starten. Ich level bloß damit, weil es sich easy level lässt. Danach
wollte ich mal Coq, Yep Coq Assassin ausprobieren. Frost Nova ist Diablo 2, Ice Nova ist Pest
und Wechsel. Ice Nova, Karst und Kirt wollte ich vorletzte League schon spielen. Und jetzt
habe ich ein bisschen, ja, habe ich genug Currency, um mir mal ein bisschen was ordentliches
zu kaufen. Das brauchen wir. Exquisite. Ich muss mal schauen, wieviel Respecs ich dann
brauche, weil der Ice Nova Spectre ist schon ein bisschen anders als der. Wenn ich das
jetzt noch mit Movement Speed kriegen würde, wäre das richtig Pog. Denn noch mit dem Labs,
habe gestern 8x gemacht, nice. Äh ich habe gestern meine ganzen Seeds, also nee die Hälfte
meiner Seeds verkauft, das hat erstmal 5x gebracht. Seeds Farm lohnt sich gerade richtig.
Moment, wo sind wir hier? Skill. Ok, das ist nur Müll oder? Aber Movement Skill kann man
nicht genug haben. So, hier gehts weiter. Und jetzt musste man einfach nur dieses komische
Siegel einsammeln und das wars. Genau, hier muss man einmal im Kreis laufen. Langsam
aber sicher kriege ich die Kampagne aus dem Kopf hin. Ohne zwischendurch gucken zu müssen,
dass ich nichts vergesse. Ist ja nicht so, als wäre die Kampagne jetzt wahnsinnig komplex.
Ist nur relativ lang. Ich bin mal echt gespannt, was die machen mit der Path of Exile 2 Kampagne.
Ich muss mal kurz die Klimaanlage anmachen. Ich bin wirklich gespannt auf die Path of
Exile 2 Kampagne, weil bisher hat ja Path of Exile sich nicht wirklich durch tolle Story
ausgezeichnet. Mal gucken, wo sie wissen, was sie eigentlich machen wollen. Ob sie eine
halbwegs spannende Kampagne für Path of Exile 2 hinkriegen. Das ist echt eine Sache,
die dem Game fehlt. Auch gerade für Casuals ist ja so eine Story Kampagne was, was viele
Leute auch dem Game, also ein bisschen in das Game reinzieht. Und jetzt müssen wir
glaube ich Kita wackeln. Machen wir das Lab? Wir machen das Lab vorher. Machen das Lab
vorher. Ah, ich war noch gar nicht drin. Eine Runde Lab. Für jemanden, der das Spiel
nicht spielt, sieht es weird aus. Ja, weird champ. Im Prinzip ist es wie Diablo 3. Nur
besser. Oder eigentlich das Diablo 3, was man sich gewünscht hätte. Obwohl es älter
als Diablo 3 ist. Habe ich den Waypoint wieder nicht mitgenommen? Lul. By the way, wir könnten
mal gucken, wie das Lab aufgebaut ist, anstatt hier blind durchzurennen. Ich hoffe, dass
ich euch nicht verrecke. PoE Lab. Normal Lab. Gucken, dass ich nicht sterbe. Gehe fort.
Open Image. Die Typen sind übelst dedicated. Die machen täglich das Labyrinth Layout
und das seit 5 Jahren oder so. So, wo muss man lang? Rechts oben? Sind wir gar nicht
so verkehrt, oder? Doch, sind wir. Ja, wir sind falsch. Wir müssen eins weiter. Rechts
oben sind wir von der Mitte aus. Ja, so ganz habe ich nämlich noch nicht gecheckt, wie
man das lesen muss, ehrlich gesagt. Ah, da ist es. Äh, wir skillen mal schnell. Bisschen
mehr Damage kann ich schaden. Kommen wir den, den, den. Dann haben wir hier live. Ich überlege
gerade, wo gehen wir als nächstes lang? Was sind schön, was hier passen? Defense brauche
ich eh nicht. Das hier runter brauche ich eigentlich viel zu viel. Defense back ich
vielleicht später. Äh, was haben wir denn hier? Das haben wir. Gehen wir hier hoch.
Strength. Increased Area. Oh, das ist gut. Das holen wir. Excellent. Noch immer Mana
Flask. Ja, es gibt keinen Grund. Ich brauche sie zwar nicht. So, wir gehen jetzt hier
hoch und holen. Das, das glaube ich ganz gut. Was meintest du gestern? Welche war gut? Witching
Aura, ne? Hab ich sogar noch eine. Stimmt, eigentlich richtig blöd. Warum nehme ich
nicht eigentlich drei? Ah, Poggers. Viel besser. Auf, noob ich Aura. Lass dich bashen.
Jetzt schreckt. Wie, du lebst noch? Ab, Fahrstuhl, next. Ich habe eigentlich immer nur die zwei
links, weil ich die mit der Maus schön auslösen kann. Wahrscheinlich bin ich schneller durch
als mit gucken. Easy, easy. Einfach kann es ja kaum gehen. Nächste Trial und dann oben
rechts Mitte, okay. Das war jetzt einfach. Geradeaus gut ist. Erstmal eine Runde kreiseln.
Nice Kampf. Knapp, ganz knapp. Ne, Crew Lab mache ich noch nicht. Das ist glaube ich
55. Da kriege ich auf den Sack. Wobei sich von den Resis anbieten würde, aber ich habe
eh genug Resis. Guck mal, ich bin over capped as fuck. Ne, was das oben rechts, ne? Äh,
Moment, Logik. Oder auch nicht. Wo ist denn jetzt was aufgegangen? Ah, hier. Laps, please.
Lass mich einfach nur durch. Boah, MonkaS. Warum kann man den Switch jetzt manchmal drücken?
Oh, sag plus hier geht es gar nicht weiter. Doch. Schön jebaited. Okay, jetzt wollen sie
aber hier wollen sie es wissen mit Lab Mechanics. Vielleicht geht es doch einfach so weiter.
Ah, MonkaS, Spikes. Ne, hier geht es gar nicht weiter. Au. Ah. Es gibt Zeug, was ich
nicht brauche. Exzellent. Big Brain Lab. Ah. Oh. Lever neben der Tür, habe ich nicht gesehen.
Aber ich glaube da geht es gar nicht lang, oder? Wir müssen hier irgendwo raus. Ja. So,
besser. Eigentlich sogar gut durch zurück gelaufen bin, weil ich hätte eh nochmal komplett
hoch gemusst. Moment, wo? Äh, weg. Wo muss ich hin? Um rechts? Okay, also bin ich eigentlich
richtig? Zumindest die Richtung ist okay. PoE raus tappen ist mutig. Ja, teilweise schon,
stimmt. Deswegen sind die ganzen Tools auch sonst Overlays. What? Aha. Moment, das ist
falsch. Da will ich nicht hin. Äh. Wie kriegt man das da oben auf? Sowas hatte ich noch
nie. Wie kriegt man das auf? Sollte man irgendwo klicken können? Kein Plan. Ja. Auch kein
Plan. Das hatte ich noch nicht. Ah. Äh. Haben die sich vertan? Haben die sich vertan?
Das rechte geht angeblich weiter und das linke geht in die Tür. Oder konnte ich es einfach
nicht richtig lesen? Klubash, hier könnte ihre Werbung stehen. Heute Morgen wurde ich
schon gebaitet, was Werbung angeht. Knapper Fight. Ein richtig knapper.
Nehm was Gescheites bei. Im Vergleich zu dem Crab, den ich gerade an habe, ist das tatsächlich
ganz okay? So. Dann kommen wir klatschen irgendwas drauf hier. Gloves. Was macht überhaupt
was? Word of War. Was ist das? Was ist das, was ich da drauf habe? Attack is performed
tripped repeatedly by a ghost imitation of you. Hä? Das Bild auch für Bossen brauchbar.
Okay. Word of Winter. Theory. Was macht das? Unleash the ice projectile and pulse with cold.
Besser als nix. So. Dann ascenden wir mal. Wir ascenden in. Bevor ich jetzt mist ascende.
Ich glaube wir ascenden in Trickstar. Wir ascenden in Trickstar und holen uns als erstes
Damage over time ist immer gut. Excellent. Trickstar. Das holen wir uns dann danach.
Dann können wir jetzt weitermachen. Mit. Kitawakillen. Kassel, das ist eines der wichtigsten
Sachen, die du machen musst für deinen Char. Das sackt richtig ohne. Also die sind teilweise
extrem OP. Du hast zum Beispiel, ich weiß gar nicht ob man das von hier zeigen kann.
Du hast beispielsweise, ne ich zeig's dir mal in passive building. Du hast zum Beispiel,
hier guck mal in der witch, in der witch ascendancy, hast du zum Beispiel solche Sachen drinne,
die zum leveln einfach nur extrem. Ok. Du hast zum Beispiel in der witch, in der necromancer
ascendancy Sachen drinne, die extrem geil zum leveln sind. Zum Beispiel das Ding hier,
dass du einfach mal plus 30, das ist, das ist eines, finde ich eines der besten Specks
zum leveln, also einer der besten Skillpunkte, oder einer der besten Nodes, die man specken
kann zum leveln. Wenn man necromancer geht. Du kriegst einfach umsonst, du kriegst einfach
mal 30 resies geschenkt. Und damage. Das ist POG. POG as fuck. Wenn man necro spielt
zum leveln. Später wenn man genug resies hat, kann man das natürlich rausspecken. Oder
sind wie gesagt, da sind richtig krasse Sachen bei. Äh Moment, wo ging's denn lang? Irgendwo
hier ging's doch zu kitava. Ah. Ne, wie gesagt, der build ist nicht, also der level build
ist nicht für Bosse. Später cast from crit ice nova ist glaube ich ganz gut. Setz zwar
kein ultra krasser Boss, Stelskiller, aber besser als sowas hier für Bosse. Also mein
main ist ja aktuell auch spellslinger, also necro spellslinger. Und der ist auch nicht
der geilste Bosskiller. Du kriegst die zwar down, aber es dauert lang und macht keinen
Bock. Dafür sind die maps halt fast as fuck cleared. Und hätte ich das gewusst, wie viel
bock und wie wenig clusterfuck auf dem bildschirm kaos spellslinger ist, hätte ich meinen ersten
char auch direkt als kaos spellslinger angefangen. Hätte ihn aber dann weiter gespielt, weil
er zum clearing geil ist und nicht so viel animationen und explosionen auf dem bildschirm
erzeugt wie vd necro. Vd necro da kriegste epileptische anfälle. Ah guck mal hier. Ah
okay erstmal soll vielleicht mal aufpassen. Off. Lass dich bashen. Meine gürtel ey was
macht der? What the hell was macht der fürn schaden auf einmal? Ich hab max resis was
ist das? Aber ich hab kaum leben ne? Wie heißt der spell? Welcher spell? Es gibt 30
Milliarden spells und skills und kombinationen im spiel. Also das game hat echt heftige
Lernkurve auch. Du meinst das hier was ich caste, das sind 3 spells auf einmal. Das ist
jetzt bash oder mich? Jetzt kann ich übrigens nichts machen, dass das story will, dass man
hier stirbt. Ne das ist 3x spellslinger. Das ist spellslinger mit contagion, das ist spellslinger
mit essence train und spellslinger mit soul rent wenn ichs finde. Spellslinger soul rent
genau. Und zum triggern frenzy mit faster attacks. Das heißt ich mach ne nahkampf attacke
und der castet alle 3 sachen auf einmal. Deswegen ist auch so viel mana reserviert. Also du
schlägst halt zu so mit dem wand. Mit dem wand. Für legrath lohnt sich das überhaupt?
Das ist das man skill gems kaufen kann, aber ich muss gar keine skill gems kaufen. Ach es
gibt auch nen skill point, ja dann, dann muss ichs eh machen. Also respect point.
Hoffentlich überseh ich nix. So lass mal kurz in mich gehen, wie gings jetzt weiter?
Ich muss jetzt an strand wieder. Äh moment. Clear twilight strand. Hab ich was übersehen?
Hab ich monster übersehen? Oh ne ich hab irgendwas übersehen oder?
Ah. Ja nico ist gut.
Da unten bestimmt, hier unten wo ich nicht. Ah hier guck mal. Oder zählt das nicht?
Hier bestimmt. Oh man, nein pass auf exile please. Das ist ja wie den of evil in diablo
2. Two remaining, wo steht denn das mit two remaining? Chat. Ah hier. Oh. GG Eats.
Ok wo habt ihr euch versteckt? Ich glaube ich hab noch nie hier gegner suchen
mussten. What the fuck?
Wo sind die? Oben in der mitte, ok wo ist oben in der mitte?
Hier. Äh.
Ich glaub die quest muss man wirklich nur einmal machen, ganz am Anfang wenn die league
neu ist. Aber mal gucken was es gibt. Ja ist nur respect. Ok das muss ich mir mal in
mein guide reinschreiben, dass ich die nicht mehr machen muss. So ich glaube die haben
hier alle nichts, die labern nur doof rum. So jetzt muss ich rüber, die diesen komischen
war god da killen. Gibt wiki eine gute übersicht. Ja ich weiß ich hab mir so ein mini guide
selbst gebastelt, dass ich nichts vergesse. Aber ich versuch grad ohne rein zu gucken
zu spielen, dass ich den kram mal auswendig kann endlich. Damit ich, weil es ist extrem
ätzend jedes mal wenn man irgendeinen character levelt in irgendwas reingucken zu müssen.
So schwer ist die Kampagne jetzt auch nicht. So jetzt muss man hier so einen rare mob killen,
damit man weiter kann. Dass der ist immer versteckt. Weil hier gehts noch nicht rein,
hier muss man jetzt rein, aber hier kann man noch nicht rein. Und irgendwo steht jetzt
ein versteckter rare mob, den man killen muss, der nicht markiert ist auf der map oder
so. Wenn man den gebashed hat, dann kann man rein. Da steht irgendwo hier rum. Ja da ist
das hier getroppt. Bestimmt übelst der Müll. Ja das kann ich beim leveling gebrauchen.
Ja 11 core das stimmt. Ich hatte ultra glück beim 6-link auf meinem main. Ich hatte eine
impulser drop und hab mit 20-30 fusions den kram 6-link diesmal. Also man muss auch mal
glück haben. Eats game ja. Richtig richtig glück. Auf der anderen seite sitzt man manchmal
jetzt hier los. Was erlauben die sich auf einmal damage zu machen? Die sollen gefälligst umkippen
wie alles andere auch. Portal portal scroll. Die map hier ist auch immer gleich aufgebaut.
Yep. Muss man eigentlich mit sinn reden, dass man den kram kriegt oder kriegt man das automatisch
ohne den kram. Das hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert. Oder kriegt man alles? Muss man nicht. Werden
wahrscheinlich auch alle speedrunner abgefuckt, wenn man warten müsste. Ich hab mir mal gewartet
zum reden, weil ich es nicht nochmal machen wollte. Alles am verrecken. So jetzt muss
ich durch zum prison und brutus 2.0 killen, wenn ich das richtige erinnerung hab. Ich
such gleich mal mein crafting-glück mit der flasche hier. Yup ist korrekt. Ich bin da froh,
dass ich ein paar leute im chat hab, die wissen was abgeht. Das sind eigentlich meine lieblings
leibs hier in allen action rpg's. So die 0815 wiesen landschaft mit skeleton bashen. Gefällt
mir in jedem action rpg am besten. Liegt wahrscheinlich an diablo influence. Ja da hast du recht. Durchrennen
ist sinnvoller. Wobei so ein cast machen zwischendurch verzögert auch kaum. Aber den hier zu bashen
lohnt sich. Woa woa woa woa. Bleed ich brauch bleed. Warte mal ich crafte mal kurz was.
Ich crafte mal kurz was. Nicht rennen wenn man blutet stimmt. Da war was. Aber ich will
mal hier ausbrechen ob ich hier irgendwas gescheites drauf krieg. Was braucht man da für was?
Ich wollt sagen den killen lohnt sich nicht. Ist ja nur müll. Du willst da crab? Ok das
geht jetzt kann ich mich zweimal einsetzen. Macht das auf quality flask? Stimmt da kannst
du höhere chancen. Aber jetzt kann ich zweimal einsetzen das bringt schon was. Muss das übrigens
anders anordnen ich muss das so machen. Weil ich drück das sonst immer mit der maus. Ja
so ist besser. Wie ist bei POE das endcam? Wie bei dir drei dass man einfach rifts und
rifts rennt? Ne. Oh. Sowas wie rifts. Also es gibt ja sowas wie rifts direkt gibt es
nicht. Das endcam sieht komplett anders aus. Und zwar du hast ein. Ich zeig es dir gleich
mal. Zeig es dir gleich mal. Also sprich du musst erst mal die kampagne durchspielen
so erst dann geht das überhaupt los. Und dann hast du hier einen atlas und jeder punkt
auf diesem atlas ist. Ich will jetzt nix über meinen mickrigen atlas hören. Jeder punkt
auf diesem atlas ist eine eigene map. Also eine eigene eine eigenes gebiet mit boss gegnern
und alle möglichen drin. Und je nachdem ich zeig es dir gleich wenn ich hier durch bin.
Genau also das endcam besteht zum kürzsten all darin. Es gibt zig tausend varianten.
Du hast zum endcam hast du einen atlas. Und jeder punkt hier der mit so einer straße
verbunden ist ist quasi eine extra karte mit eigenen monst also mit mit monstern drauf mit
einem eigenen boss drauf. Und jede dieser karten gibt es in unterschiedlichen schwierigkeitsstufen
von blau von weiß über gelb bis rot. Also von t1 bis t16. Diese maps kannst du entchanten
mit verschiedenen stats. Also je nachdem wie schwer die maps dadurch werden um so besseres
loot droppt auch. Und jede map hat drei verschiedene challenges. Und damit schaltest du dann weitere
belohnungen frei die du auch noch reinkraften kannst mal blöd gesagt in dein endgame atlas.
Bis du das hier alles completed hast dauert. Dazu kommt noch dass du zwischendurch bosses
spawnen kannst. Da kriegst du solche watchstones. Die watchstones kannst du auch entchanten was
dann alle maps in diesem gebiet beeinflusst. Beispielsweise dass es spezielle gegnertypen
gibt extra extra bossen was auch immer. So dann muss man die gegner hier baschen nachdem
man hier die maps gemacht hat. Also wenn man hier einen boss gespawnt hat kann man dann
hier die gegner baschen und in der mitte kriegt man dann einen endboss. Wie heißt der typ
serius der awakener glaube ich. Und der kann auch mal super krasses zeug droppen dann.
Und dann geht das ganze wieder von vorne los was die bosse angeht. Aber bis du jede
map auf maximalen level hast mit den challenges und alles die ja auch deine droppchancen beeinflussen
das dauert eine ganze weile. So und dazu kommt dass es noch zig weitere mechaniken gibt
die man so auf den ersten blick gar nicht sieht. Weil die haben fast alles was es in
den vergangenen leaks gegeben hat noch in dieses endgame reingepresst. Es gibt beispielsweise
extra preachstone geschichten das ist sowas wo permanent monster spawnen. Da kann man
sein map device upgraden auf 5 slots und es gibt wirklich 100.000 100.000 geschichten
zu machen. Also wenn du so spielst wie ich und nicht jeden tag 10 stunden grindest sondern
nur mal einen tag am wochenende 10 stunden grindest. Und ansonsten relativ verhaltens spiels
ja da kannst du locker eine league damit beschäftigt sein das hier alles zu machen. Ich spiele
meistens so zwei drittel einer league und dann bin ich zufrieden und dann hör ich auf
bis zur nächsten league. Ich spiele auch selbst erst wieder seit metamorph. Das ist die vorletzte
liga gewesen. Nein das brauche ich nicht. Der account ist von 2013 also richtig richtig
alt noch aus der beta. Aber ich habe da eine ganze weile nicht gespielt. Dann habe ich
metamorph wieder angefangen weil es mir ultra langweilig war. Weil ich wusste was ich machen
sollte was ich spielen sollte. Wie wäre es denn mal wieder mit perso weg sei. Und irgendwie
bin ich dann hängen geblieben. Delirium habe ich nicht richtig gespielt. Habe ich irgendwie
an Zeit keinen bock kann sonst was. Aber jetzt diese league wird wieder ein bisschen reingekrindet.
Es ist eines der besten endgames die ich kenne muss ich echt sagen. Also auch der übergang
von kampagne zu endgame ist wunderbar gemacht. Deswegen spielen es wahrscheinlich auch mehr
leute denn je. Genau stimmt medics sagt auch noch stimmt habe ich ganz vergessen. Und es
gibt noch was das ist nicht wirklich wie rifts. Aber es ist insofern wie rifts dass es unendlich
tief ist. Das ist quasi ein dungeon wo du so einen so einen gondeln wie nennt man das.
Was im bergwerk gibt so eine lore. Nein lore heißt es lore. Wie heißt das so ein wagen
aus dem bergwerk halt. Durchschieben musst von karte zu karte und da gegner killen musst.
Und es wird halt auch je nach tiefe immer schwerer. Das ist so ein bisschen wie rifts
vielleicht nur dass es diese rift upgrade mechanik und schlüsselgeschichten nicht gibt. Oder
weiß gar nicht was schlüssel diese rift steine da. Genau und in dieser liga gibt es möglichkeit
sehr viel krasse items selbst zu craften wenn man das will. Gibt so ein garten den kann
man aufleveln und zeugs drinnen aufstellen und upgraden und gedöns machen und samen
sammeln und samen upgraden und mit samen dann items craften und so. Aber ich mag die crafting
mechanik nicht ich verkaufe das einfach alles gibt auch dicke kohle. Ich verkaufe alles
die man sieht. Doch ich würde immer liga spielen. Ich würde immer liga spielen. Mein
standard hat auch seine vorteile es ist vielleicht keine bullshit mechanik drin wie man nicht
mag. Also wenn man die aktuelle league mechanik nicht mag. Absolute high end item sind besser
verfügbar aber liga ist viel aktiver. Liga ist viel aktiver und ich finde es auch gerade
das gute das abwechslungsreiche daran dass es halt immer eine neue league mechanik gibt.
Ich würde eigentlich immer liga spielen. Standard spielen ich weiß mache ein paar aber
mein fall ist es jetzt nicht unbedingt. Ich finde es ist auch gerade was den reiz ausmacht
das kannst du dann drei oder wie lange läuft so eine league dreieinhalb monate. Was der
fliegt. Übrigens ihr erinnert euch vielleicht daran den boss hatten wir gestern schon mal.
Der eine boss kommt vier mal. Also nicht der hier. Ich habe vergessen wie er heißt. Irgendwas
mit M. Dieser einen boss den wir gestern auch schon mal hatten der kommt vier mal. Ne moment
da da da da lang. Es gibt ne storyline ja aber die storyline von passive exile ist nicht
das wofür man es spielt. Die story ist wirklich schlecht. Ich habe mir mal gedacht okay max
du hast jetzt schon ein paar mal die kampagne durchgespielt. Guckst du dir mal ein video
an wo erklärt wird um was es geht. Und ich habe mir ein video angeschaut 10 part video
wo eine wirklich die ganzen details erklärt was in jedem akt passiert und es ist so eine
dermassen trash schrotz story einfach nur. Das ist definitiv definitiv nicht die stärke
von dem spiel die main quest. Stimmt du hast recht es gibt eine story die erklärt warum
der gegner vier mal da ist. Aber unabhängig von der story und die logische erklärung dafür
ist nicht die story sondern das grinding games gecontent recyceln wollte. Was ich auch
okay finde wenn man sich überlegt wie viel wie viel drinne ist. Muss diesen komischen
ziegen menschen boss bashen jetzt. Das amulett ist nicht schlecht meinst du das da. Mal gucken
wenn ich genügend stats habe. Movement speed huge. Ah ein bisschen resi da. Movement speed
kann man nie genug haben. So das game möchte von mir jetzt dass ich den boss hier nicht
töten darf sondern ich weiter rennen muss. Ich mach gleich den enchant auf was drauf
dann habe ich wieder max resis. Ich hab letztens ein video gesehen von einem auf youtube der
hatte irgendwie ein bild am start mit 280 prozent movement speed. Ach gotte fuck. Also
der ist der ist ungefähr in dieser geschwindigkeit über die ganze map gerannt. Was war da. Einen
schmutz eigentlich egal. Passt das fuck ja aber echt. Der ist wirklich die ganze zeit
in dem tempo also in dem tempo wie ich jetzt hier noch meine teleports mache ist der da
durchgefetzt. Übels hat. Glaub ich kann main road einfach laufen da komm ich richtig raus
weil ich brauche hier nichts. Das nächste also wenn ich das richtige erinnere ich muss
aus dem gebiet raus ins nächste gebiet. Im nächsten gebiet gibt es ein site gebiet wo
ein boss drin ist den muss ich killen für einen skillpoint und dann renne ich durch
bis zum ende des achts. Und dann hoffe ich euch nichts vergessen hab. Kann man was gucken.
Das zusätzliche dex macht es jetzt auch nicht fett. Passt eigentlich. Mach das. Irgendwo
hoch muss ich das weiß ich noch hoch ins seitengebiet boss killen. Genau hier muss ich rein boss
killen. Eigentlich muss ich hier gar nichts großartig machen außer durchrennen boss killen
und wieder zurück und zum ende des achts. Wo ist noch den eingang zum boss finden. Moinspiele
gerade das erste mal poe ich kann nicht chat lesen und laufen da bin ich zu lowbrain. Moinspiele
als erste mal poe und frag mich wie man am besten an passende items reinkommt. Wenn du
vom trade league spielst dann indem du auf die offizielle trade seite gehst und dort
nach item suchst die dir was bringen. Poe trade geht auch. Poe trade ist ein bisschen
langsamer wenn du einfach nach item suchst die du brauchst. Vorausgesetzt du weißt was
du für stats brauchst. Wenn du self found bist wovon ich nicht ausgebe wenn man neu
ist dann ist eh schwieriger. Guck mal hier wie sie auf den sack kriegt der boss. Lul
voll geschreckt. Oder bist du noch am laffeln x vase und brauchst
gute items zum laffeln. Also das du überhaupt was kriegst. Da ist nämlich das was cassone
schreibt da gibt es gerade am anfang für zauberstäbe also für warns gibt es ein paar
richtig nice recipes die du selber craften kannst mit spell damage und alles. Das habe
ich bei ein paar speedrunnern gesehen die craften sich am anfang immer extra warns mit
spell damage. Ja und was nicht schlecht ist wenn man ungefähr weiß wie man skillen will
weil da kann man sich schon raussuchen welche gems man bei welchem quest reward kriegt und
ob man vielleicht ein paar sachen braucht. Also so ein pass of building offen haben hier
ist nie verkehrt. Ja so ein gucken was man skillen will. Dann verskillt man sich auch
nicht aus versehen. Du brauchst einen passenden 4 link. Du kriegst bei manchen quests garantierte
4 links in der story quest. Ansonsten kannst du 4 links relativ easy craften. Also die chance
für auch 4 links ist ich weiß nicht wie hoch ehrlich gesagt aber es geht. Auf der
anderen seite du kannst dir auch einen lootfilter einstellen der dir die das hätte ich beispielsweise
gerne am anfang gewusst dass sowas gibt. Du kannst dir lootfilter einstellen und dort
vorher definieren was du für gear highlighted haben willst. Hast du auf deinem plan bis
10 mercy lab zu machen? Ja. Es gibt eine coole seite für lootfilter. Genau und beim vendor
kann man auch gucken. Ja es gibt eine richtig nice seite für lootfilter. Da kannst du auswählen
was du haben willst also sprich wie restriktiv das ganze eingestellt sein soll. Also wenn
du gerade erst anfängst würde ich sagen strikt oder semi strikt. Der hat ja auch ein paar
details was angezeigt wird. So und dann kannst du das ganze ausprobieren. Kannst du hier
quasi so testen ob der alles anzeigt was du willst. Und die lootfilter sind eigentlich
relativ gut auch für low level sachen eingestellt. Der highlighted dir defaultmäßig auch in
der gewissen level range dann auch vor links und sowas. Also die sind ganz praktisch und
am ende kannst du hier dich sogar einloggen in passive exile und die lootfilter direkt
sunken in dein game. Gut der ist jetzt schon ein bisschen älter. Aber ich glaube man hat
es verstanden. Von wann ist der? Der ist neuer soll ich vielleicht den nehmen? Das hilft
einem. Weil ansonsten wenn man sich überlegt ohne lootfilter du wirst ja erschlagen von
loot explosionen bei den gegnern. Also ohne lootfilter ist das game fast nicht spielbar.
Das ist später noch viel mehr ich mach gleich mal ne rote map später. Kann ich jetzt mal
zeigen das haut ich komplett weg. Also endgame spiele ich jetzt als lootfilter dann immer
sehr strikt erstmal drin. Ich renn hier einfach durch. Was für ein char spielst du gerade?
Das ist ein einmal shadow ascendancy trickster und dann das hier als chaos bellslinger. Den
link hab ich mir abgeguckt aus nem video. Ich kann den mal posten. Dass du den genau
dann gucken willst. Ja und für alle die noch nicht pass of building haben das ist das wichtigste
tool überhaupt zum character erstellen. Da kann man die sachen nämlich planen ohne dass
man im game sein muss. Und da kann man wenn man hier diesen pastebin link hat geht man
einfach in pass of building sag import import from pastebin macht die url rein und dann
importiert man und hat halt hier den ganzen kram am stück. Wobei das auch nicht sonderlich
optimiert ist was er hier gemacht hat. So meiner bescheidenen einschätzung nach. So ich glaub
ich muss jetzt komplett einfach durch bis zum ende des acts und das wars. Ich glaub mir
muss nix mehr spezielles machen. Und wenn man so noob ist wie ich da kann ich eine sache
noch empfehlen. Guckt euch youtube guides an. Also youtube guides von leuten die halt auch
vorzeigbare ahnung haben also sprich die auch. WTF was ist das? Das hab ich ja noch nie gefunden
hier. Also sprich die halt auch character haben die in der aktuellen league gut gut
abgehen. Reddit ist immer so ne sache. Auf reddit sind die leute ziemlich pepega im kopf.
Da hast du zum beispiel welche die dir erzählen wollen. Ne bild was quasi mehr als 20 chaos
kostet ist kein richtiges bild. Das ist der schwachsinn. Weiß nicht was mit reddit abgeht.
Für die ganzen high end builds brauchst du ein bisschen currency. Außer vielleicht
necro vor 2 seasons. Da konntest du ja wirklich mit nichts t16 machen. Und nachdem es bei
dem spiel sehr viele versteckte mechaniken gibt von dem man halt von dem man das gamelink
sagt ist youtube videos gucken und paar guides angucken wenn man neu ist sehr praktisch.
Ja so ist echt so siehts echt auf reddit aus. Weil das bild hier jetzt was ich da hab das
kost auch kein zum level das kost halt auch nicht viel. Davon abgesehen aber das braucht
man auch nicht weil ich brauch eh nur nen 4 link. Aber später wenn man das endgame mässig
spielen will klar kostet das auch currency. Ich glaub es geht rechts lang. Zum beispiel
es gibt eine sache die zeige ich euch mal später. Wo ihr super einfach das ist geheimtipp
ist es nicht mehr weil ich habs auch in dem youtube video gesehen wo man total einfach
in der aktuellen leak mechanik sich sehr gute items craften kann ohne aufwand oder aber
sogar seeds verkaufen kann und geld machen kann. Muss ich mal ausschweilen hier. Weil
es gibt nen spot später im spiel weil ich glaub ich zeig den euch gleich wenn ich den
ich hab mit dem anderen scharf. Es gibt nen spot in dem spiel da kommt man innerhalb von
10 sek an die aktuelle leak mechanik dran und genau stone t stone genau das meine ich
an die aktuelle leak mechanik dran und bekommt seeds zum craften oder seeds zum verkaufen
es gibt leute die kaufen sogar die query seeds. Aber gerade zum einsteiger gear craft ist
es wirklich nice. Ich machs natürlich nicht. Ich machs natürlich nicht weil ich hasse
craften. Ich mag das überhaupt nicht an das crafting in der liga gefällt mir null aber
ich verkauf die seeds. Aber man kann es eigentlich nur empfehlen das zu machen weil das top gear
ohne aufwand gibt. Natürlich lieber bashen anstatt craften. So der act ist gleich vorbei
dann zeig ich euch mal kurz welchen spot ich mein. Spot.
Ein harvest garden sieht auch total mickrig aus. Ich hab drei stationen und fünf container
das wars. Alle anderen seeds werden verkauft. Wenn ich mir da von manchen stream an die
garten angucke der 5km groß ist und 25 stationen und alles enthält. Der neueste trend ist
ja auf twitch hab ich gesehen die machen alle house of mirror gambling in streams. Wahrscheinlich
ist mittlerweile das spiel schon zu langweilig die wollen lieber knossi style glücksspiel
betreiben. Wobei das ganze spiel ist glücksspiel. So den act mal mal kurz fertig. Jetzt zeig
ich euch mal schnell was ich mein. Hier ist nämlich irgendwo ein waypoint. Ich lock mal
kurz auf eine andere chartung. Wenn ihr in act 9 angekommen seid dann kommt ihr irgendwann
das ist ziemlich am ende von act 9 in dieses gebiet. Ihr könnt hier einfach im kreis laufen
und instant am start entweder hier oder hier oben ist die aktuelle leak mechanik. Da geht
ihr hin, crappt euch die seeds und startet neu. Neustarten. Startet neu. Unten zieht
mechanik. Zag. Crapen. Also total ohne aufwand kriegt ihr das seeds zum craften. Easy as fuck.
Guckt wieder hier. Also ihr seht das ist ziemlich einfach. So und mit diesen seeds könnt ihr
dann euch ziemlich gute items craften die euch lange Zeit carryen werden. Das sind zwar
nur 65er seeds aber für gears was euch erst mal am anfang von maps carried reicht das
oder eine ganze weile in maps carried reicht das. Und ihr könnt auch wenn ihr gar nichts
zu tun habt die seeds farmen und im discord verkaufen. Gibt es hier diesen discord hier
und dort gibt es trade channels für bulk transfer seeds. Es gibt eigentlich 4 hauptkategorien
wo man die seeds verkauft. Entweder die quarry seeds das sind die 65er. Da gibt es leute
die kaufen tausend stück für ein exalt oder sowas in dem dreh. Danach gibt es die middeltier
map seeds die sind 76 also die. Ab mittelgelben maps gibt es dann level 76 seeds. Die kannst
du für ungefähr 0.4 chaos pro seed eher 0.3 chaos pro seed 0.3 bis 0.4 chaos pro seed
kannst du die verkaufen. Dann gibt es die 81er plus seeds und es gibt thornweed seeds
die sind teuer die kosten 15 chaos pro seed. Also das einzige was man machen muss die seeds
bevor man die verkauft nach thornweed filtern weil dafür kriegt man mehr. So und mit der
mechanik könnt ihr easycolle machen diese liga. Wo wir gerade schon in der stadt sind
holen wir uns mal den kram hier ab. Manchmal gibt es garantierte quadlings. Ich muss mal
kurz den kram abladen im stash. Mal passives. 13 am ende müsste ich 24 haben. 22, 24 am
ende. Ich habe keine portals mehr. Da steht da 0 wenn man ein. Ah so ok das wusste ich
gar nicht. Ich gucke am ende immer ob ich 22 oder 24 habe. Ah eine runde delirium gibt
es exp.
Das muss ja bei delirium richtig abfuck gewesen sein als es viel mehr von diesen portalen
hier gab dass du nicht richtig looten kannst weil die zeit läuft ja auch weiter während
du lootest. Warum machen sie es nicht so dass du quasi das während delirium nichts droppt
und alles am ende droppt. Gut da wäre der bildschirm ja komplett voll gewesen. War zu
wohnen was war das da unten. Ah nice. Ok alles klar. Die dinger sind teilweise recht
viel wert. Warum droppen gerade so viele cluster und jewels was ist denn hier los. Hier ist
es. Ok das war jetzt aber mickrisch was hier getroppt ist. Ok das sind auch low dinger
die bringen nix. Oh. Gut die anzeige von awaken a trade bei diesen rare items ist sehr fragwürdig
also ob man dafür wirklich 6-9 chaos kriegt fragwürdig. Eher nicht. Erstmal was skillen
hier. Guck mal wir haben neue skillpoints null. Area of effect damage wenn du gucke da ist
mir nicht viel skill. Leben wir skillen noch ein bisschen life. Life ist nicht verkehrt.
Strength kommen wir auch skillen live runter. Und jetzt als nächstes den gemsockel noch.
Bisschen mehr life könnten wir echt haben. Ich glaube ich crafte mir gleich ein bisschen
life hier. Boah ich hab zuviel. Ah hier können wir ein bisschen life drauf craften. Hier
können wir auch ein bisschen life drauf craften. Hier können wir nix drauf craften. Hier können
wir. Ja mal gucken klar. Bisschen mehr life ist nicht verkehrt. Das ist übrigens das
grill aus act 1 falls es einem aufgefallen ist. Auf gib gas. Am schlimmsten war das
am Anfang alle splitter einzeln gedreht. Echt? Boah das ist abfuck. Life in softcore.
Gar so wenig soll es aber nicht sein. Ich mag eigentlich build von hardcore spielern
ganz gern. Weil die sind halt maximal safe. Da stirbst du nicht. Oh mr craps.
Hast du Geld für POE ausgegeben? Oh ja. Hab ich. Ich hab stash tabs gekauft. Microtransactions
gedürtens gekauft. Ist aber eines der spiele wo ich das freiwillig gemacht hab und tatsächlich
sogar gern gemacht hab. Man braucht nix aber stash tabs empfehlen sich. Stash tabs bieten
sich an dass man ein paar stash tabs kauft. Und dann am besten auch mal eins zwei von den
großen. Dass man nicht so viel micromanagen muss drin. So act fertig. Ich hab mir auch
noch ein paar supporter packs geholt weil. Irgendwo muss das twitch money ja hin. Nee
keine ahnung. Braucht man nicht. Aber was man braucht sind. Warum rede ich eigentlich
gerade mit allen npcs. Durchchen geblieben. Braucht man überhaupt nicht. Aber stash tabs
sind nicht verkehrt. Überlege auch mal in POE reinzuschauen. Stehen nur nicht auf ingame
bezahlen gedürtens. Du brauchst nix. Du brauchst nix. Wie gesagt das einzige was ich empfehlen
würde wären paar von diesen stash tabs. Die kannst du benennen. Kannst du farbe geben.
Also zwei stück davon finde ich ganz praktisch. Also mindestens zwei stück davon finde ich
ganz praktisch. Du kannst hier einfach das ist so ein stash tab was ich für maps verwende
um einfach die sachen rein zu droppen. Sieht man ja. Müsste schon mal durchgehen. Eins
kannst du zum verkaufen benutzen. Mal angenommen man möchte alle items die hier drin sind verkaufen.
Und da kannst du hier oben sagen public exact price jedes item 15 chaos. Also ist Schwachsinn
machen wir jetzt nicht. Weil. Weil ich nix verkaufen will davon weil das dump crap ist.
Und dann auch noch eine Sache die ganz praktisch ist finde ich ist der maps stash wo du alle
maps rein machen kannst. Und danach suchen kannst du hier zum Beispiel habe ich keins
mehr. Okay. Look out. So. Aber ansonsten also du brauchst nix. Du kriegst du hast standardmäßig
zehn stash tabs. So welche glaube ich zehn stück kann sein dass ich komplett falsch
legt. Schon lange her. Aber du musst nichts verkaufen. Und also den value den du hier
bei passive exile kostenlos kriegst gibt es bei wenig anderen spielen. Da kann man sich
beschweren. Und irgendwie müssen die letztendlich Geld verdienen. So also weiter geht es. Wo
sind wir stehen geblieben. Das ist. Akt sieben. So wie war das mal ich muss mal kurz in mich
gehen wie ging es hier weiter. Ich glaube ich muss jetzt. Ich muss irgendwo links hin und
in den Dungeon das weiß ich noch. Genau links hin in den Dungeon muss ich. Genau links
hin in den Dungeon dort die map holen. Dann auch guck mal noch mal ein Delirium. Das machen
wir jetzt aber nicht. Gehe jetzt hier direkt raus. Oder auch rechts rum. Bin mir gar nicht
sicher. Irgendwo. Irgendwo geht es hier auf jeden fall um die Ecke. Ich bin mir relativ
sicher links rum. Ja. Genau. Crossroads. Dort muss ich jetzt runter. Dort muss ich noch
mal ein Delirium. Das möchte aber von mir das Delirium machen. Mal gucken ob ich hier
noch irgendwie Waypoint kriege. Das Parzallmodell ist wirklich fair. Also bei Mobile Games und
solchen Sachen ja da bin ich ja auch immer gut am flamen. Aber Paths of Exile ist wirklich
fair. Also mal kurz in mich gehen. Ich muss jetzt hier in den Dungeon. Ich muss mir dieses
komische Item holen und dann muss ich hoch Chamber of Sins das Item einsetzen und zum
Boss. Das war es glaube ich. Dann ist der Act hier relativ straight forward. Die Leute
ich lese den Global Chat gar nicht. Was ist hier gerade getroppt? Die Dinger lohnen sich
diese League. Das ist halt oi. Oi 3 Head Chat. Ich habe den Chat trotzdem ganz gerne an.
Wtf. Gebatet. Geht es doch auf der anderen Seite weiter. Ja ging doch auf der anderen
Seite weiter. Lass den Main Chat immer an. Ich finde das teilweise ganz unterhaltsam
weil so viel Bullshit gepostet wird. Man könnte den Chat ausmachen. Weiß nicht soll
ich den Chat ausmachen? Das letzte Mal als ich gefragt habe die Leute gesagt nein auf
keinen Fall Chat anlassen weil Chat lustig. Und ich lasse den Chat auch immer an weil
es ist irgendwo lustig. Weil es ist so dumm. Das da halt auch. Es ist teilweise so dumm
was ich lustig finde. Cute Chat. Nee der Main Chat ist nicht cute. Der Main Chat ist
im kurzen Teil ziemlich dämlich. Aber seid froh. Ohne Scheiß. Ich bin ja normalerweise
im englischen Main Chat. Aus Gründen irgendwie hier auf dem zweiten Windows Account mit
der PoE Installation im deutschen Chat. Ich finde den mal ausnahmsweise finde ich den
globalen englischen Main Chat fast noch schlimmer als den deutschen. Eine der wenigen Fälle
wo das mal so ist. Ach guck mal da oben geht es gleich weiter.
Das klingt nach einem ganz guten Level Item. Aber nicht für mich aber vielleicht für
was anderes. Nö die Trial habe ich schon. Oben war die Trial. Das habe ich mir gemerkt
dass das so ein Sarg ist. Die Trial ist im zweiten Stockwerk. Aber Trial brauche ich
ja nicht. So erstmal alles bashen. So und jetzt zurück zum Waypoint und rauf Chamber
of Sins. Ich hoffe ich habe es richtig im Kopf. Chat. Ich versuche es nämlich gerade
komplett mal ohne Guide zu spielen. Also ich habe mir selbst so einen Mini Guide gebastelt
mit ein paar Sachen, dass ich nichts vergesse. Den habe ich auf dem zweiten Bildschirm auf.
Aber ich versuche wirklich so wenig wie möglich drauf zu gucken, dass ich es mal langsam jetzt
aus dem Kopf gebacken kriege die Kampagne runter zu spielen. Also wenn sie das nicht
nerven nächste League werde ich mit dem gleichen Build anfangen. Nur dass ich da nicht umspecken
werde sondern Endgame weiter spielen werde erstmal zum Farmen. Spellslinger macht unglaublich
Spaß zu leveln und ist OPS Fuck. Also Chaos Spellslinger. Noch besser als Necro Spellslinger.
Hallo. Hallo. Hat sich sehr Kokona angehört gerade. Kokomret. Spellslinger, VD ist zu
stark. VD dürfen die gerne nerven, aber Chaos Spellslinger macht mir noch mehr Bock, weil
es nicht so viel Cluster Fuck auf dem Bildschirm ist. Wollen wir mal fragen was du für ein
Bild spielst? Also aktuell ist das ein Chaos Spellslinger. Kann ja auch das Bild posten.
Das habe ich aus, das habe ich nicht von mir wohl gemerkt. Das habe ich mir geklaut aus
einem YouTube Video. Zum Leveln. Also bis, bis ungefähr 28 31 mit dem Bogen sinnlos rumgerannt
dann geswitcht auf Spellslinger und wenn ich dann so 75 oder so bin respecke ich komplett
das eigentliche Bild. Weil eigentlich wollte ich mir Karst und Crit, Ice Nova Bild machen.
Wollte ich schon vor 2 Leaks spielen. Habe es aber nicht gebacken gekriegt. Und jetzt
habe ich bisschen Currency übrig. Jetzt habe ich was. Komm auf gehts. Ich weiß nicht wie
sinnvoll es ist ehrlich gesagt mit sowas hier zu leveln und dann komplett umzuspecken. Aber
mir ist es lieber ich kann easy as fuck leveln und komme durch ohne jegliche Probleme und
gebe dann halt noch mal ein bisschen Respeck Points aus. Ich meine man kriegt bis zu 18
Respeck Points aus der Kampagne. Ich glaube das waren 18. Und die Respeck Orbs die sind
auch nicht so teuer. Dann habe ich lieber hier angenehmes Leveln und easy Endgame einstiegen
und dann specke ich um. Als cock zu leveln ist furchtbar. Yep kann ich nur zustimmen.
Ich habe bis 32 mal probiert einen Skill Tree zu machen der ähnlich ist zu dem was
ich am Ende brauche. Das ist es aber einfach nicht wert. Das ist übelst nervig gewesen.
Levels to Ice Nova in der Offer Minde ich kaufe mir einfach das Juwel dann. Ich brauche
eh noch die ganzen Gems noch und ich brauche auch das ganze Geh noch. Das einzige was
ich schon habe ist die Waffe die habe ich glücklicherweise schon vor einer Woche gekauft
habe ich für 80 Chaos gekriegt heute ist die glaube ich bei 120. Und ein paar Kleinigkeiten
habe ich schon aber das meiste das meiste muss ich mir noch kaufen. Aber ich habe ungefähr
so ein 7x Hold Budget dafür sollte ich halbwegs was spielbares hinkriegen. Eigentlich müsste
es sogar ziemlich gut spielbar sein diese League. Weil gerade durch dieses Harvest Crafting
hast du halt diesmal ziemlich viele ultra geile Items verfügbar im Vergleich zu sonst.
Moment bitte stehen geblieben. Genau ich muss muss hier raus. Warte mal. Komm wir machen
ein Town Portal. Ice Nova mit Wirbelwind genau. Exzellent genauso. So sieht es aus. Also das
Bild das ist das mein Level Bild und das Bild was ich später machen will ist das hier.
Bild Bild Bilding. Ja das was ich später leveln will was ich später auf was ich später
umspecken werde ist das hier. Cock. Yep. Cock. Cluster. Ich habe mir das aber noch nicht
großartig angeguckt kann sein dass ich noch ein bisschen feintunen muss und wahrscheinlich
werde ich es auch ohne Cluster Jules spielen falls das geht. Was wird sonst. Alter Passive
Exile please. Es war nichts da wo ich raus getappt bin ja. Jetzt sind irgendwelche Zombies
an mich rein geschlurft. Ja ich weiß dass man den Dialoge skippen kann. Man kann sogar
irgendwo irgendwo hinklicken hat mir gestern jemand erzählt. Ich dachte man muss auf
continue klicken. Ah wieso umkippen. Kleinen. Möpse. Aber zu leveln macht Spellslinger
übelst Bock. Das Hideout will ich nicht. Wobei ich habe mir vorgenommen ich habe mir
vorgenommen alle Hideouts zu sammeln dass ich endlich mal alle freigeschaltet habe.
Ich habe alle Hideouts bisher ignoriert die ich nicht haben wollte aber nachdem die Liga
übergreifend sind ist es eigentlich blöds nicht zu machen. Vielleicht will man ja doch
mal ein anderes benutzen. Dann muss ich nicht zurück. Ich spiele niemals ohne Cluster die
sind OP. Ja aber die sind doch teuer wenn du die richtigen haben willst. Was hast du
aktuell für ein Hideout. Ich habe die ganze Zeit Sanctum gespielt. Das ist da wo dieser
Innocence Kampf ist. Und jetzt habe ich Climawood Forest oder so. DLC. Microtransaction Hideout
für viel zu viel Geld. Für das was es bringt. Es bringt ja im Prinzip nichts außer cool
aussehen. Und ja das ist recycelt die Map aus Act 3.
Ich hätte gerne das Strand Hideout noch. Das für das Strand Hideout muss man aber
soweit ich gelesen habe die Atoll Map Farmen bis man mal random Glück hat das das Hideout
spawned. Letztens bin ich in ein cooles Hideout reingejoint. Der hat um seinen Waypoint einen
Käfig gebaut das die Leute die in sein Hideout rein können die sich nicht mehr bewegen können.
Das war eigentlich eine nice Idee. Moment. Ich bin verwirrt muss ich hier raus. Ja muss
ich genau. Ah jetzt muss ich in die Act 2 statt. Übrigens Act 2 nicht Act 3 was ich
vorhin gesagt habe. In die alte Act 2 statt und Boss bashen. Hab auch schon mal jemand
Portal zugemacht weil er mir was falsches verkaufen wollte. Ja also ich muss sagen ich
bin vor Trade Scammers bisher verschont geblieben. Wurde dir schon mal gescampt oder versucht
zu Trade Scam. Macht aber Damage äh. Alter ist ja gut. Will das aber wissen der Gude
hier. So ausgegrußt. Du bist schon mal auf den Preisfixer reingefallen. Das sind die
schlimmsten. Das ist teilweise übelste Chebathe Geschichte wenn du hier auf die Trade Seite
gehst und suchst irgendwas. Wobei das. Dann hast du manchmal Leute drin die haben dann
das auf 2 Chaos stehen. Und dann denkst du 2 Chaos ist aber echt billig. Dann schreibst
dir den an und bekommst nie eine Antwort. Das liegt daran weil der Typ hofft dass Leute
nachgucken wie was äh wie teuer was ist und sehen ah 2 Chaos und verkaufen ihm das für
2 Chaos. Übelste Chebathe Scam. You got Chebathe. Guck mal den Preach. Den machen wir noch mal
mal. Woah. Keck wait. Gut ich bin nicht der stabilste ja ich muss ich sehe es ein.
Mal erstmal die Fireflies hier. Vor allem bei Sixlings wird oft gescampt. Inwiefern
dass die dir die falschen Farben geben beziehungsweise dass es keine Sixlings sind. Dass sie quasi
ein Item nehmen was genau so aussieht und keine Sixlings hat. Also ich habe mir dafür
mal auf wie gesagt auf einem anderen Windows Account. Also nicht auf meinem Streaming Account.
Ich habe so ein Trade Tool mal installiert was dir in der in der Truhe anzeigt wo die
Items liegen die man verkaufen will dass man die schneller findet. Und ich glaube das kann
aber auch irgendwie dabei unterstützen dass man nicht so leicht gescampt wird. Ich glaube
das kann ich habe es aber nie ausprobiert. Also das ist jetzt rein was ich im Kopf habe.
Das Tool kann dir auch irgendwie ein Overlay anzeigen beim Traden dass du nicht so leicht
gescampt wirst. Habe ich aber noch nie ausprobiert. Aber das beste das beste Tool was Preischecks
und sonstige Sachen angeht ist immer noch hier. Awakened PoE Trade. Das ist so praktisch
dass man einfach mal nachgucken kann. Ok taugt das was? Ist das so was wert? Nein das ist
nicht. Alter ist ja gut. MonkaS. Fünf Monate bis zum Silvester Stream. Wer sagt denn dass
es dieses Jahr einen Silvester Stream gibt? Du hast immer Ja gesagt. Ja wahrscheinlich
gibt es auch einen Silvester Stream. Also es gibt aktuell keinen Grund warum es nicht
einen Silvester Stream geben sollte. So erstmal hier unten noch clearen bevor ich den Boss
mache. Benutze PoE Overlay den Fork. PoE Overlay habe ich auch benutzt bis die auf
die Idee gekommen sind an. Wem gehört Overwolf? Teamspeak? Keine Ahnung. Bis die App Store
Sellout gemacht haben. Und dann habe ich Awakened PoE Trade verwendet und den Fork hatte ich
mir gar nicht mehr angeguckt. Oder muss man hier erst drinbleiben? Ne ne. Moment habe
ich eigentlich alle Fireflies gefunden jetzt hier? Ja habe ich. Kann ich wieder raus. Du
du du. Wupp wupp wupp. Genau Overwolf. Ich weiß es gar nicht. Wem gehört Overwolf?
War das Teamspeak? Oder war das etwas eigenes? Irgendwo hier müsste ein Altar sein. Wo man
wo ich noch für eine Quest hin muss. Nein nicht hier hin da muss ich gleich weiter.
Irgendwo ist hier ein Altar wo ich eine Quest brauche. War ein Addon für Teamspeak. Ja
ich weiß nicht ob es dir noch gehört. Mittlerweile ist es ja was mit eigenem App Store und irgendwie
so welche Mölle. Ok wo ist der Altar? Wo ist der Altar? Er kann doch nicht so weit sein.
Ich bin fast einmal über die ganze Map gerannt. What? Bin ich blind? Wo ist er denn? Du hast
die Quest dafür nicht. Das macht nix. Wenn man den Altar anklickt kriegt man die Quest
und kann direkt ins Dorf. Bin ich jetzt blöd? Wo ist er denn? Kann man nicht den Altar einfach
anreden und man kriegt die Quest? Gucken wir mal. Skill excellent.
Jetzt habe ich das. Aber das müsste man vorher auch machen können. Oh gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich meine der Rest ist Crap aber 20 Movement Speed wäre genauso gut für den Rest den ich
habe. By the way musste man nicht noch eine Quest für den Dude machen hier direkt davor?
Hier gab es doch noch genau das habe ich vergessen. Wobei ich da aus dem Kopf nicht weiß ob es
Skillpoint Quest war oder ob es irgendwas anderes ist. So gut kenne ich den Kram dann doch noch
nicht aus wenn ich. Da da unten ist er. Mit einer Wisdom Scroll plus Scouring Up kann
man ja auch ein Skill Book. Hä wie? Dann hätte man ja unendlich viele Skills. Ach nee das
ist nur Flasks.
Glaub ich auch nicht. Nein glaub ich auch nicht. Glaub das ist G-Bait. Ach guck mal
da oben müssen wir hin. Könntest du mir was preisen? Ich kann es probieren aber ich habe
keinen Plan. Wär nur wirklich auch nicht der Pro. Hast du schon mal auf der Trade Seite
geguckt? Aber wir haben im Chat Experten hier. Dann schieß mal los. Und jetzt müssen wir
weiter. So und jetzt sind wir mit dem Act schon mehr oder weniger durch. Wir müssen
jetzt hier durchrushen, dann die Spinne, die Spoda, Spodas killen. Spoda killen und dann
ist der Act durch. Nein das machen wir jetzt nicht. Habe es gerade er meint. Was dein Level
um eins verringert. Ein nicer G-Bait. Wobei das zu offensichtlich war das es nicht funktioniert.
Weil sonst hätten wir unendlich Skill Points. Das wäre irgendwie etwas, ach nee doch man
kann rüber. Etwas OP. Tankt das was? Äh. Nö.
So wir brauchen zwei Items. Wir müssen den Ausgang finden und wir müssen ein Quest Item
für den Skill Point finden. Und beides ist meistens recht nah beieinander. Muss aber
nicht sein. Doch da oben war es doch. Ah, ah, Monkeys. What the fuck. Ist ja gut. Mops
regt euch ab. Was ist denn hier los? Die Mops drehen ja voll. Die drehen ja vollkommen frei
Alter. Was ist mit den Mops denn los? Gucken was es für Items gibt. Ah, kann man immer
welche brauchen. So also was sagt T-Stone? Ich habe in einer Seite geschaut und dort
ist ein Item was 10x kostet und zwar. Also ich glaube nicht. Dass ein Item was einen
speziellen Enchant hat 10x wert sein kann. Da würden die Leute ja lieber Tag ein Tag
aus Lab run. Genau, genau, gute Idee. Paste, paste, paste das mal in Chat. Dann können
wir das mal machen. So, die Mapchi baitet mich regelmäßig. Ich muss immer durch die
halbe Map hin und zurück laufen. Dass ich finde wo es lang geht. Über dem Buch ist
es schon mal nicht. Echt? Kriegst du wirklich Enchantments? Na gut, das sind wahrscheinlich,
es gibt ja auch sau mäßig. Stimmt eigentlich. Eigentlich ist es logisch, weil es gibt ja
wohl sau viele Enchantments und es gibt sicherlich einige die übelst OP sind mit oder halt ewig
brauchst. Was zum Beispiel, was ist denn ein Enchantment was mehrere X-Rolls kostet?
Jetzt mal interessieren. Die zahlen Leute gerne, weil wir 900 Labs runn, naja das stimmt.
Keiner. Lab runs sucken. Außer natürlich man ist Lab runner, jetzt nix gegen dich.
Ich machs nicht gerne. T-Stone du kannst trotzdem mal pasten. Vielleicht können die Leute da
ein bisschen was zu sagen. So also wo müssen wir jetzt weiter skillen? Life schadet auf
jeden Fall nix. Den Kram hier unten, den Kram hier unten schenken wir uns mal mit Evade.
Oder? Was meint ihr? Lohnt sich das für Survivability hier unten? Akrobatics und Gedöns? Oder lieber
mehr Damage? Lohnt sich? Ist insane. Na wenn es insane ist, dann specken wir das. Massive
Insane. Ja ok. Wenn ihr euch da so einig seid, dann mach ich das. Ist mein erster richtiger
ernster Trickstar Char jetzt. Ich weiß ich hab noch einen anderen hier auf 70, aber der
ist dann einfach nur da. Also auch wo ich dann auch mal ein Speck in der Richtung spielen
will. Ich hab die letzte League nur Witch gespielt, die League davor nur Witch gespielt.
OP Necro Caster Action vor zwei Leagues. Necro mit Skeletten. Das war wirklich absoluter
Kacknoob Build. Genau das Richtige für mich wieder zum Einstieg in passive exile. Necro
Skelette Build, wo du mit quasi null Invest T16 Maps face rollen konntest.
So als würde ich den Boss killen, danach machen wir das nächste Lab. Oder irgendwann
demnächst machen wir das nächste Lab. Ich finde die offizielle Trade Seite auch am besten.
Bei mir liegt es daran, ich hab ja POE Trade dadurch, dass ich jetzt lange nicht gespielt
hab, nie großartig verwendet. Und als ich wieder angefangen hab gab es die offizielle
Trade Seite schon, das heißt ich konnt mich gar nicht so sehr an was anderes gewöhnen.
Ja, CoA Sound. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie soll ich das richtig ausspringen? Bei mir ist halt
genau umgedreht, ich hab nur die offizielle verwendet, weil ich zu der Zeit gar nicht
gespielt hab, wo es das noch nicht gab. Also doch schon, aber halt gerade nicht. Wie gesagt
der Count ist von 2013. Ah, ah, ah, aha. Flame Dash beste. Ops, fuck. Die ganzen Speedrunner
sind Smoke, Smoke Mine. Smoke Mine und Dash. Komm, den Preach machen wir noch. Vielleicht
gibt es irgendwas Gescheites. Ich hab das letzte Mal schon gesagt, bin verreckt.
Schon wieder. Ja, Boss Damage ist nicht so meins gerade. Wo sind wir lang? Hier, oder
da? Jawoll. Bisschen mehr Defense wäre ich nicht verkehrt. Er schreddert alles. Guck
schon einmal Respec Points, was später. Boss, wo bist du? Den Dungeon mag ich nicht. Erinnert
mich ein bisschen an den Diablo 2 Flayer Dschungel Dungeon. Falls ihr noch jemand kennt.
Kennt ihr noch diese Flayer Dinger aus Diablo 2? Diese kleinen Teile, die übelst Damage
gemacht haben, wo man überhaupt nicht mit gerechnet hat. Kennt ihr noch jemand? Ich
weiß übelst alles klar Boomer, aber vielleicht kennt ihr da ein oder andere noch. Die waren
übelst heftig. Du hast immer gedacht, oh ja hier kleiner Furzgegner und Bäm. Diablo
2 Flayer. So, please Gegner. Wo ist der Boss? Gift Boss, ich will hier raus. Mag den Dungeon
nicht. Spodas. Genug Wal Ops. Spodas, kann nicht mehr weit sein. Ah, da geht's lang.
Okay. Endlich. Raus hier. Da hier. Emo, NPC am Start. Es gibt gar keine Emos mehr. Wo
sind die eigentlich alle hin? Ich weiß nicht, wie ich da gerade drauf komm. Wo sind die
eigentlich alle hin? Oh. Alle weg. Und zack. RIP.
So. Sterben please Boss. Jawoll. Exit 8, 8, äh 8, 8. Oh, raus hier. Raus hier, Alter.
Oh, ich hasse diesen Dungeon. So viele Spodas. Fehlt bloß noch Spodaman. Weird Champ. Ich
gebe zu, der war echt schlecht gerade. So, wir gehen jetzt zur Waypoint, dann machen
wir das nächste Lab. Äh, ja. Wo geht's lang? Irgendwo hier müsste jetzt eigentlich ein
Loch in der Mauer sein. Da. Dann schnappen wir uns den Waypoint und machen das Lab und
dann schnappen wir uns den Waypoint im, am Lab, den ich mir immer noch nicht geholt
habe, weil übelst bescheuert. Einfach durch. Oh ne, geht's gar nicht lang. So, jetzt. So,
das haben wir hier im Rucksack einmal kurz verkaufen. Ah, das können wir mal. Wobei,
so, wir sind, wir sind mal nicht so, wir, wir. Good luck. Äh, Moment, für was war das
noch mal? Das hab ich vergessen. Ah, das war, ähm, Akt 4 nochmal abgeben. Äh, nicht
Akt 4, Akt 7. Das hab ich irgendwie voll verpeilt. Bei dem hier, ne? Gibt's nämlich noch ein
Skillbook. Du könntest nach einer Chest suchen mit 4 links. Ja, äh, ja, ja, ja, da hast
du recht. Das wäre deutlich sinnvoller, als mit meinem Tabula rum zu rennen, was überhaupt
keinen Sinn macht. Also, was ich eigentlich brauche, weil keine 6 links. Gucken wir mal
kurz. Level, Level 55. Hallo, 55. Ähm, Chest, ne, Body, Body Armor ist das. Ähm, wir brauchen,
wir gucken mal, ob's welche schon gibt mit, äh, 4 mal, 4 mal 4 links. Man, die Sockelfarbe
kann man theoretisch auch selbst machen. Denk an die Stats Requirements. Reicht das hier
nicht? Maximum Level 55. Int. Oder Evade Base. Oh. Ähm, ok, wir machen mal Life. 70.
Ah. Ok. So, gucken wir mal, was gibt's denn hier? Warum eigentlich, warum, warum nehmen
wir nicht, warum nehmen wir eigentlich Int und warum nehmen wir nicht Dex? Weil Dex hab
ich doch auch ordentlich. Ich hab sogar mehr Dex als Int. Moin. Babsi. Weil du 4 blau bist.
Ex- Oh, Big Brain Chat. So. Ammonia. Wir können einfach mal gucken, was schon 4 blau hat.
Guck mal, können wir sogar noch selbst dann, ne? Maximum Life, Maximum Mana, Fire Resistance,
das Ding holen wir uns jetzt. Ah, ne, ne, Moment, what? Moment. Ah, 4 blau, so rum.
Ne, das war nicht gelingt. War nicht gelingt. Was, was noch ganz cool wäre, wenn man noch
was drauf, wenn man noch was drauf forgen könnte. Guck mal, das ist doch nice. Cool, 92 Life.
Was haben die Explode drauf? Ne, oder? Ne, ne. Das wär's jetzt, wenn die Explode drauf
hätten. Die Dinger sind teuer. Moment hier. Explode. Ich hab letztens nen Trick gelernt,
da kann ich wie ein Tilde davor machen. Explode. Physical. Und da kann man besser suchen. Das
ist halt total OP, ne? Ne, vor allem gibt's die glaube ich nicht mit 55 requirement. Ne,
das wär auch zu übertrieben. Das wär auch, die Dinger sind auch echt teuer. Die Dinger
sind auch richtig teuer. Moment, Maximum Life. Kommen wir mal 80. Ja, ne, das ist doch,
das ist doch AFK. Hier links. Irgendwas, irgendwas, wo ich noch was draufcraften kann, wäre nicht
verkehrt. Total Element Resist, stimmt. 160, das ist vielleicht bisschen viel, ne? Ne, das
kommt, das ist Leveling Crap da. 104 Life, Life Rack, Fire, Lightning. Und ich kann auch
was draufcraften. Ist doch eigentlich gar nicht übel. Das Ding hier ist doch gar nicht
schlecht. Oder Kassun, was meinste, hier bei dem anderen. Die ersten Autos sind 5 Link,
stimmt. Aber da kann ich nix mehr draufcraften. Scheiß drauf. Ich brauch kein 5 Link. Ich
brauch eh was komplett anderes dann. 104 Life, gut ist. Komm, scheiß drauf. Ich brauch jetzt
irgendwas, bevor ich da eh mich rummache. AFK ist er, ok. Dann nehmen wir den ersten
Dude. Ah, ok, er hat mich schon invited. Visit hideout. Das war jetzt der Dude mit 2 C, ne?
Mal kurz gucken, dass ich nicht gescampt werde. Alles klar, passt. Accept. Wunderbar. Thank
you Exile. May Tukohama bless you. What the fuck. Das ist irgendwie so Tradebot gedürzt.
Jetzt haben wir mich ordentlich live. Wir können sogar noch ein bisschen was draufcraften.
So, exzellent. Brauchen wir noch irgendwie Defense? 75, 75. Ich bin wunschlos glücklich.
Ich könnte ein paar Chaos, ich guck mal ob ich ein paar Chaos Resists noch schnell draufmache.
Weil das könnte mich noch mal kurz im Blatt machen. Stimmt. Schauen ob ich hier vielleicht
ein bisschen Chaos. Falls ich das nicht schon geplockt hab, doch das ist geplockt. Was
kann man hier überhaupt noch drauf machen? Geht hier noch irgendwas drauf? Warum geht
hier nichts mehr drauf? Es müsste noch eins frei sein. Ist übelst Müll drauf. So.
Life of Shield. Ist Life of Shield. Kriegt man da mehr für das Ding raus? So. Jetzt
gehen wir da hin und machen das Lab. Ist eh nur left link hier. So, jetzt machen wir das
da. Das da oder das da. Movement Speed. Movement Speed speck'n wir. Movement Speed. Exzellent.
Danach speck'n wir Movement Speed. Ja, perfekt. Waypoint, ja. Genau 55, wie das passt. Ja,
da hab ich noch nicht so genau den Durchblick ehrlich gesagt, wann ich was wie craften kann.
Ich weiß es gibt POEDB oder POE Craft App oder irgendwie sowas. Ich glaub POEDB war's,
wo man gucken kann. Also Wahrscheinlichkeiten und sowas. Und welche Sachen, Suffix, Prefix
und Gedöns sind. Und wenn man wie craften kann, aber so ganz gecheckt hab ich es nicht,
weil manchmal sind Resis drauf und du kannst trotzdem Resis drauf craften. Ich glaub das
ist die Frage, ob Kombiresis sind oder einzelne Resis oder irgendwie sowas. Das hab ich noch
nicht so hundertprozentig kapiert. Jedes Einer hat Platz für sechs. Genau, das weiß
ich. Wenn du auswendig weißt, was Pre und Suffix sind. Ne, weiß ich nicht. Das ist das
Problem. Deswegen, da muss ich nachgucken. Das hab ich noch nicht so hundertprozentig
durchschaut, wann wie was ist. Übrigens wir müssen mal hier gucken. Mercy Lab. Wir sind
jetzt da, oder? Ah, hast recht. Ich wollt grad sagen, das deckt sich überhaupt nicht.
So, also wir sind jetzt da, wir waren da, sind jetzt da raus und müssen jetzt rechts
oben hin. Morka Stachlos, Morka Stachlos. Ah. Aufhören. Genug Stachlos. Was um Resis
zu können, brauchst du ein Open Suffix, also Max zwei. Was Max zwei? Max zwei was? Ah,
ach so. Ach, das dürften schon drauf sein. Ah, verstehe, verstehe. Zwei FPS. Ach, deswegen
muss ich mal ein Frame Limiter einschalten. Die Option hab ich an. Das hab ich an. Oder
hab ich das hier nicht an? Nein, keine Microtransactions. Aber das hab ich an. Jetzt wird man das gar nicht
sehen, ne? Ah, das ist so geil, dass die schon eine Map dafür fertig gemacht haben. Richtig
huge. Oh, es exploded, ich muss hier weg. Morka Stachlos, geh weg. Stachlos. Ich hab
übrigens gar nicht geguckt, wo ich lang muss und ich trau mich jetzt nicht raus zu tappen.
Äh, nein. Gibt eh nur einen Ausgang. Aha, da sind wir. War das was Gescheites? Cold
Resistance, Thunder. Ne. Trap. So, eine Runde. Izharo, Izharo, Izharovion, wenn die ausspricht,
Gbaton. Izharo, ich glaub Izharo spricht bei ihnen aus. Wieder ein super harter Fight.
So. Äh, Moment, wir sind jetzt da. Wir müssen jetzt, äh, rechts oben wieder. Exzellent.
Also hier lang. Tja, gut. Erstmal 30 Milliarden Gems leveln. Oh. Alter, NA klicken. Kona-Klicker.
Da sind wir doch. Passt. Eins zu weit. Zumindest hört man das von den Voice Actors,
ja. Ich muss ja sagen, so die Lore und die Story, ich geb's mir selten. Ist doch irgendwie
mega wie er ist. Oh, das sind die, das sind die Stachel, Stachel-Explodier-Typen. Warte
mal. Ich geh mal kurz weg und guck mal, wo wir lang müssen. Äh, wir müssen Zweite
vorne rechts. Also irgendwie Mitte, Mitte. Eigentlich immer grad aus in dem Fall. Eigentlich
immer grad aus. Schauen wir mal, ob wir's finden. Ab 5 Stunden, ab 5000, wollte ich
mal sagen. Ab 5000 Stundenperiode weiß man, dass man ein Angry Exile-Boy ist, ja. Also
die Lore ist wirklich, nur ja, sie ist vorhanden, aber nicht gut. Ich hab mir mal eine Videoserie
angeguckt, da hat jemand erzählt, da hat einer erzählt, zehn Videos zu jedem Act, die Story
und das wurde von Act zu Act dümmer. Und vor allem, als sie dann angefangen haben,
der Content zu recyceln, fünfmal den gleichen Boss und sowas, dann wurde es immer beknackter,
dass sie das irgendwie einbauen können. Easy Fight. Guck, wie viele Kies da droppt.
Huge. Sanctified Flask und Mana? Brauchen wir nicht. Die Frau, die da alles vorliest.
Ja, ich, genau, die hat die komplette Passive Exile Lore erklärt und ich dachte mir die
ganze Zeit nur Cool Story Bro, kann man ja weniger sagen. Cool Story Girl. Tja, Boots.
Das mach ich da nicht drauf. Das mach ich da nicht drauf, weil ist es nicht so, dass
dann die Level Requirements steigen und ich sie nicht mehr mit Load Shards ausrüsten kann.
Ja, das ist doof, weil der hier ist ja schon Enchanted. Der war ja auch schon Enchanted
und er hat Level Requirements. Wo sieht man eigentlich Level Requirements? 54, Kock, kann
ich wieder nicht vergessen. Erricht Verwenden. So, also, was mit jetzt Respect? Ghost Dance,
Movement Speed. Exzellent. Alter. Was bedeutet Enchant, genau, du kriegst einen zusätzlichen
Effekt auf dein Item. Du hast hier Lab Enchantments, gibt's eine ewig lange Liste mit Sachen, die
du zufällig auf deine Items, also die überschreiben nix. Die kriegst du zufällig zu allem anderen,
was auf den Items drauf ist, was sie echt OP machen kann. Es gibt halt viele Enchantments.
Du kannst Helme, also im normalen Labyrinth kannst du Gloves Enchanten, im mittleren kannst
du Boots Enchanten und im Krölen kannst du glaube ich den Helm Enchanten und im oberen
alle drei. Oder immer inklusive, inklusive dem vorherigen immer. So, gut, auf geht's
weiter. Lass mal kurz in mich gehen, was war jetzt als nächstes? Ich glaube als nächstes
war, genau, in die Kanalisation, Boss killen und dann die Wiederbelebungs-Quest machen
danach. Hey, mal eine Frage, ja, schieß los. Exzellent. Komm, wir können mal ein bisschen
looten zwischendurch. Da warte ich noch drauf, dass die Sound-Microtransactions einbauen.
So Level-Ups, oder gibt's wahrscheinlich sogar schon. Da bin ich bestimmt der Einzige, der
auf die Idee gekommen wird. Wahrscheinlich gibt's schon Sound-Microtransactions und ich
hab's bloß noch nicht gesehen. Weil ich mein, Spell-Optik-Microtransactions gibt's ja auch
schon. Weil wenn, dann muss ich grad mal gucken, was es für meine Spells gibt. Hauptsache
mehr Geld aus dem Fenster schmeißen. Für Spells, die ich dann nicht mehr entkämmt verwenden
würde, Hauptsache Geld aus dem Fenster schmeißen. Was gibt's hier, was gibt's hier, mal kurz
gucken. Cosmetics. Was, Celestia Cat Soul-Rent. Kann man sich das nicht irgendwo angucken?
Gibt's da nicht irgendwie ein A-Brivey-Video hier? Okay, ziemlich sinnlos. Aber irgendwie
gefällt's mir. Was, was kosten da Kram, kostet, nee das kostet, also 50, ich mein die Dinger
sind teuer. 150 Punkte für ne Animation. Okay, das ist es mir glaub ich nicht wert,
2 Points. 15 Dollar, 15 Dollar für ne Katzen-Animation. Ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, ich mein,
ich werd den Skill später nicht mehr verwenden, ja. Worth it. Ich weiß nicht. Ich spende dir
15 wenn du das jetzt kaufst. Quatsch, bezahle ich selbst, muss mir keiner was spenden. Ich
hab so viele Stubs vom Tancer bekommen in letzter Zeit, da kann ich mir das aus... Soll
ich mir das kaufen? Ist das ernsthaft? Okay. Aber, ich muss Points kaufen. Da muss ich euch
kurz ausmachen um Points zu kaufen. Und ich muss mal hier ne... Weil ich bin hier gar
nicht eingeloggt. Okay, Chat, ich mach euch kurz aus, log mich ein, kauf mir Points und
dann kauf mir ne Katzen-DLC. Was ein Schwachsinn. Hätte ich gar nicht geguckt, hätt ich mal
gar nicht geguckt, da hätt ichs mir jetzt nicht kaufen müssen. Kaufs nicht. Ja, was
denn jetzt? Doch, jetzt kauf ichs. Crosswalk. Ich muss Capchas lösen, Moment Leute, ich
muss Capchas lösen. I'm not the robot, yes, ich weiß. Niemand sollte den Track unterstützen.
Ich finde es ist nicht schlecht, es ist zwar zu teuer, es ist viel zu teuer, aber irgendwie
müssen die Geld verdienen. Gerade bei Passive Exile finde ich das angenehm. Finde ich das
angemessen. Gerade bei Passive Exile finde ich das angemessen, weil das ist eines der
besten Free to Play Sachen, die man so spielen kann. Und irgendwie müssen die Geld verdienen.
So, buy Paypal. Kaufe jetzt Points Leute. Checkout Paypal, easy. Wenn man bedenkt was
eine echte Katze im Moment kostet, macht man einen Schnapper. Das stimmt, allerdings
ist eine echte Katze gar nicht so teuer. Also, ich hab hier eine. Außer, dass die viel
frisst, kostet die nicht sonderlich viel. Und die frisst massig. Deswegen ist auch so
dick. So, Points gekauft. Massive Katze, ja. Massive, huge Katze. So, Passwort nicht geleakt.
Ich mach euch wieder an. Äh, Moment. Zeigst du euch mal die dicke Katze. Da ist an der
ist schon gut was dran, ja. An der ist schon gut was dran. By the way, DLC Teppichskin.
By the way, ich hab's übertrieben Leute. Pass mal auf. Ähm, ich hab mir gedacht,
wenn man grad auflädt, kann man doch einfach mal 40 Dollar aufladen. Why not? Okay. So
rent cats. Easy clap. Wie baut man im Garten wieder was ab? Shift oder Control, Rechtsklick.
Okay, den brauchen wir auf jeden Fall. Kann man hier unten, Alke? Warte mal, Warte mal,
Warte mal, Warte mal. Skill, skill effects, skill, skill effects. Cat. Nee, gib nur das.
So, rent. Bye. Excellent. So, was gibt's denn für die, was gibt's denn für die anderen
noch? Es ist total geil zum Fenster rausgeschmissen grad, ne? So rent cat. Ah, excellent cats
am Start. Was haben wir sonst noch hier? Contagion, Celestia. Der ist, der ist nicht
so gut. Arcane, Contagion, den find ich tatsächlich ganz cool. Der ist ganz cool, was haben wir
sonst noch? Cosmetics, Essence Train. Nee, das ist alles nicht so geil. So, aber jetzt
ist, jetzt können wir eigentlich nicht mehr verlieren, also. Guck mal, die haben, guck
mal, die rollen sogar, wenn sie gegen die Wand klatschen. Perfekt. So, jetzt kann uns
eigentlich nichts mehr passieren. Jetzt kann uns nichts mehr passieren. So, Boss, wo ist
der Boss? Guck hier, mit den Cats geht's gleich viel mehr ab. Basher Cats. Äh, was?
Max mal kurz auf Topikfrage. Habe ich jetzt drei Monate die Peißengrundlagen erlernt,
jetzt weiter vertiefen oder auch mal andere Basics von Java, C++, etc. lernen? Gut, also,
Basics von C++ würde ich erstmal aufschieben. C++ würde ich generell nie machen, außer
es muss unbedingt sein, weil C++ die nervigste und ekligste Programmiersprache der Welt ist.
Vielleicht nehmen wir Brainfuck. Äh, Java ist nicht verkehrt, sich die Basics ein bisschen
anzugucken, weil Java eben im Business-Bereich voll angesagt ist. Und ansonsten, wenn du
drei Monate Peißen gemacht hast und damit gut zurechtkommst, würde ich mal vielleicht
ein bisschen Web-Anwendungen rumbasteln. Css, HTML, JavaScript. Weil das ist was, da kommt
man eigentlich heutzutage gar nicht dran vorbei. Also, ein bisschen Web-Grundlagen, Basics
zu haben, geht eigentlich gar nicht ohne. Ich würde mir ein bisschen JavaScript, Css,
HTML angucken. Das kannst du ja auch mit Peißen als Backend machen. So, habe ich jetzt den
Waypoint gekriegt? So, wenn ich richtige Erinnerungen habe, muss ich jetzt hier hoch, ähm, da raus
und dann diese Wiederbelebungs-Quest machen. Doch, ich bin, langsam, langsam kriege ich
die Kampagne aus dem Kopf hin. Catch my breath. Und damit man die Wiederbelebungs-Quest machen
kann, muss man erst so ein komisches Quest-Item finden. Das bei mir immer unten war. Guck
mal, ob es diesmal auch unten ist. Ey, die Cats sind nice, die gefallen mir. Es ist doch.
Microtransaction Cats, beste. Ein Schnapper für 15 Dollar. Wer kann da wieder stehen?
Quasi, quasi geschenkt. Also, ähm, Moment, ich muss gerade mal kurz die Gegner killen.
Was hast du? Java steht als erstes auf dem Modulplan für mein bevorstehendes Studium.
Deswegen wollte ich mir das auf jeden Fall anschauen. Ja, Peißen ist der Anfang. Ja,
also wenn du studieren willst und die Java machen, dann wäre auf jeden Fall das. Dann
hast du was für die Zukunft gemacht. Allerdings, wie gesagt, an, äh, Grundlagenwebentwicklung
kommt heute niemand mehr vorbei. Außer vielleicht Mainframe-Coball-Entwickler. Und ich sage
jetzt nicht das Übliche zu Coball dabei, dass es am Aussterben ist, weil das sagt man
seit 50 Jahren schon. Tolman-Baschen. Ehrlich gesagt, was richtig geil wäre, wenn der Fabian
auch Pass of Exile spielen würde. Da könnten wir den ganzen Tag Pass of Exile grinden.
Hast du noch mal über PoE-Guilde nachgedacht? Äh, nö. Bis jetzt schon nicht. Ich mein,
PoE spielt doch eh da für sich allein, oder? Ist ja kein MMO. Sanctify Lifeless. Ah, nice.
Kann man nur zweimal machen. So, und nun muss ich ins nächste Gebiet. Ich hoffe, ich vergesse
nichts. Jetzt muss ich ins nächste Gebiet. Dort ist auch noch eine Skill-Quest. Da muss
ich so komische Gambling, keine Ahnung, Wachen oder so killen. Und dann durch bis zum Ende.
Das war es dann mehr oder weniger. Lunaris, Solaris, Temple und fertig. Man kann coole
Leveling-Unix in die Kiste legen. Ok, dafür ist es natürlich nice. Ich glaube, dass eine
Guilde in Pass of Exile doch jetzt, wo du es hast, ist gar nicht mal so übel, weil Pass
of Exile gewisserweise ein bisschen der MMO-Social-Aspekt fehlt, falls man danach sucht. Wenn man einfach
nur vor sich hin grinden möchte, dann nicht. Aber spielen wahrscheinlich auch viele Leute.
Also wahrscheinlich finden das viele Leute gar nicht schlecht, wenn sie ein bisschen
Gilden-Chat und ein bisschen socialisen kann neben harter grind-Action. Da hat man auch
einen Chat, da müsste man sich nicht mit dem Global-Chat aufhalten. Es gibt hier auch
irgendeinen Trick, den habe ich aber noch nicht gecheckt. Ich glaube, man muss da lang,
wo eine Leiche vor dem Tor liegt. Habe ich auch bei irgendeinem Speedrunner gesehen.
Genau, man muss da lang, wo eine Leiche vor dem Tor liegt. Vor die Haustür gehen? Nein,
Quatsch. Er geht vor die Haustür. Wer macht denn sowas? Wissen Sie, schon sind wir richtig.
Guck, hier ist auch wieder eine Leiche vor der Haustür. Ich glaube, man muss immer da
lang, wo die Leiche vor der Haustür ist. Ja, echt geiles Strat. Dann stimmt das was,
der Typ-Erzähler. Das habe ich letztens in irgendeinem Speedrun gesehen. Immer da lang,
wo die Leiche vor der Haustür liegt. Jetzt einfach durch hier. Big Prane Speedrun-Strat
hier. Alter, wie die umkippen. So krass. Und es macht mega Spaß, das zu leveln. Das Bild.
Eats Game. Ja, Eats Game, Eats Life. Das ist nicht nur Eats Game. Oh, fuck. Ich wollte
gerade sinnlose Emotes klicken. So kurz aufpassen. So, jetzt muss ich mal in mich gehen. Jetzt
muss ich Lunaris runter den Boss killen. Ah ja, ja. Running low on cuties. Leute, wisst
ihr, dass ich heute mehr oder weniger den ganzen Tag online war? Heute Morgen ganz
normaler Aufwach-Stream. Und jetzt irgendwie schon wieder drei Stunden Pass of Exile. Ich
war eigentlich, seit ich aufgestanden bin, online. Bis mal kurz zum Mittagessen-Pause.
So lang, so lang bin ich nie online. Sonntags-Stream plus, ja. Übrigens, wenn euch das ganze
gefällt. Ich weiß, dass die Leute nicht unbedingt am Start sind, weil sie den harten Pass of
Exile-Crimes sehen wollen, sondern die regelmäßigen Zuschauer eher wegen Technik-Sachen. Aber
wenn ihr am Start seid und es gefällt euch trotzdem, ich freue mich über jeden Follower
und jeden, der im Chat aktiv ist. Und nice, dass so viele da sind. Auch wenn es was anderes
ist, als ich sonst mache. Die Katzen-Microtransaction gefällt mir. Nein, hier geht es nicht lang.
Hier geht es nicht lang. Moshi moshi, running claw and cuties. Genau, so sieht es aus. Pass
auf, sonst kommen die Nammers. Ich dachte, du würdest nach Primes abfragen. Nee, hat
es erledigt. Du hast ja schon uns abgegiftet bekommen. Ja, wir wissen ja, das beste Subway-Sandwich
ist das Prime-Sub. Das war ein richtiger Pains-Champ-Witz, oder? Mit dem Subway-Sandwich.
So, Boss-Bashing. Aber alles in allem kommen wir doch echt gut durch die Kampagne
durch. So, wo geht es lang? Boss. Das ist irgendein Portal, wo man lang muss, das kann
ich mich noch dran erinnern. Irgendein Portal, wo man durchporten muss, Boss-Kill und dann
kann man gleich wieder zurück. Geht es ja hier lang? Nope, nope, falsche Richtung. Ich
habe in meinem Char 38 Stunden für die Kampagne gebraucht. Ja, ich bin beim ersten Char mit
Sicherheit auch massig lang. Das, was die Kampagne am meisten beschleunigt, ist, wenn
man sich ein bisschen ausmännlich merkt, was man machen muss. Weil ansonsten muss man permanent
die Guides gucken, oder noch schlimmer, nach der Ingame-Quest gehen. Die Ingame-Quest-Anzeigen
ist hier quasi komplett optional. Du kannst einfach zum Ende der Quest rennen und kriegst
Quests. Ah, hier sind wir. Der Boss kann nichts, der Boss sackt. Okay, Facetanken, easy.
So, wo muss ich? Jetzt stehe ich gerade auf dem Schlauch. Wo muss ich denn jetzt noch
mal hin? Jetzt hängt es gerade bei mir. Ich muss, ah, ich muss zurück. Ich muss zurück
in Sumpf, äh, nicht Sumpf. Abwasser, Abfluss, Gedöns. Ja. Und jetzt da unten. Ha, ich habe
mich dran erinnert. Exzellent. Ich versuche ja, ohne Guide zu gucken, das zu machen, dass
ich es endlich auswendig kann. So, jetzt muss ich Badehaus durchrennen. Fahrrad fahren,
bis denn. See you. Bewegung. 2020. Ich habe mich heute bewegt vom Bett zum Schreibtisch.
Exzellent. Reicht ja auch. Für heute zumindest. Also ich finde, das ist für heute schon weit
genug. Sieht bei ihr nicht anders aus. Wahrscheinlich ist es bei den meisten so. Ein paar von euch
sind ja auch schon seit dem Aufwachstream da. Aber das nächste ist, glaube ich, eine
der wenigen Maps in dem Game, die exakt immer das gleiche Layout hat. Alter, wie die umkippen.
Moment, da kann man. Da kann man durch Flame daschen. Man braucht das richtige Timing.
Man braucht das richtige Timing. Ich schaffe es nicht mehr. Krass. Lull. Einfach mal durch
die Wand teleportiert. Weiter. Exzellent. So, wir müssen jetzt noch ein Skill Point
holen. Links rum. Erst mal diesen Miniboss hier baschen, der nix kann. Die Raum kippt
einfach nur. Und jetzt muss man links. Links raus. Habe ich den Waypoint mitgenommen? Leute,
kann man irgendwo sehen, ob man einen Waypoint. Ich glaube hier World Screen. Ja, habe ich.
So, hier erstmal den Skill Point holen. Hier sind die nervigen Gegner am Start, die explodieren
und Irrs Damage machen. Also nicht die, sondern die. Diese dicken Fächer hier. Die gerade
nicht da sind. Ist das WoW? Lull. Nein. War das ernst gemeint? Das sieht doch überhaupt
nicht aus wie WoW. Außerdem Spielekategorie sagt Passer-Wagg-Style. Warum nicht wieder
Reaktor-S? What? Das eine hat mit dem anderen absolut gar nichts zu tun. Ja. Oh, die Dinger
sind nervig. Die manövles Damage. Und da mage. Boah. Viel zu viel. So. Oh, oh, oh. Da
muss ich aufpassen, da darf ich nicht so reinrushen. Erstmal Boss-Baschen. Der Boss kann übrigens
gar nichts. Der Sucked-Huge. Außer Ad-Spawn, die auch nichts können. Äh, ich glaube das
ist auch so ein Boss, der wieder gescriptet ist, weil er was macht. Also den kann man
gar nicht wegbursten. Der will zweimal Gegner spawnen. Was sind das eigentlich für komische
Blasen hier? Was ist denn das für ein Skill? Den Blasen. Das kann ich bestimmt ausbacken.
Ah, das kann man aber verkaufen für extra Zeug. Scheinen ja mehrere Bosse nichts zu
können. Die können fast alle nichts. Die können fast alle nichts, bis auf ein paar
der Map-Bosse. Welcher Boss kann was in dem Spiel? Wie gesagt, die Endgame-Bosse sind
nicht ganz so ohne. Aber ansonsten, in der Kampagne kann glaube ich kein Boss was. Äh,
wir müssen übrigens wieder zurück. Über älter. Ja, das wird das zähle ich unter Endgame-Boss.
Die können was, ja. Auch die Zwischenbosse im Atlas sind jetzt auch, je nach Gier, teilweise
gar nicht so easy. Und Cyrus ist halt auswendig leer. Und ich kriege trotzdem noch auf den
Sack. Manchmal. Also, fast immer. Moment. Das ging hier oben raus. Ach, da. Moment. Ne,
das Hideout hab ich doch schon. Ne, in der Kampagne nicht wirklich, denke ich auch. So,
und nun als nächstes Lunaris Tempel Bosskillen. Jetzt ruckelt das Game erstmal. Perfekt.
Gerade so ein Game sollte nie ruckeln, wenn viele Monster auf den Bildschirm kommen. Der
hauptsächliche Sinn von Path of Exile ist ja Monster killen. Und wenn es ruckelt, wenn
du Monster killst, ist irgendwie Fail. Können wir, please ein paar mehr Packs spawnen, damit
ich vom Delirium-Portal auch was hab? Spawnt ja nix. Ja, endlich mal. So, ich hab die Delirium-Mechanik
auch nicht so hundertprozentig gecheckt, weil wie gesagt, ich hab letzte Liga ja nicht
gespielt. Ich glaube, je länger die Runde läuft, umso stärker werden die Gegner. Oder
ist es, umso weiter man sich bewegt hat im Nebel, umso schwerer werden die Gegner. Also
hat es was mit der Reichweite zu tun, die ich im Nebel zurücklege, oder ist es nur
die Zeit, wie lang die Delirium-Geschichte schon aktiv ist? Das hab ich noch nicht ganz
kapiert. Reichweite, okay. Oh, Reichweite in Form von, wenn ich im Kreis, ach, weiter
weg vom Spiegel verstehe, okay. Dann ergibt's Sinn. Müsste Reichweite sein. Ja, Reichweite
vom Spiegel, das ergibt Sinn. Jungle-Map beste. Du meinst, weil Jungle-Map so im Halbkreis
geht, oder? Ach nee, du meinst, weil Jungle-Map immer geradeaus ist, ne? Jungle-Map stimmt,
ist immer geradeaus. Und sogar noch durch ne Höhle durch zum Teleporten, wo richtig
weit weg geht. Also sprich, du meinst, weil halt die Monster richtig stark sind und richtig
gut droppen dann, weil man weit vom Portal weg ist, oder? Yep. Also meine Lieblings-Map
ist Park. Einfach im Viereck rennen und durch sein. Was ist denn grad so die Meta-Farm-Map?
Hyokon, danke schön. 13 Monate Hyper-Subscriptionär. Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment. Wo hab ich's?
Alter, wie's oben kippeln? Das macht so Bock, das Spell-Slinger-Build eben zum Leveln. Massive
Bock. 59,59, wir sind optimal mit dem Kartenlevel unterwegs. Und wir nehmen jetzt noch mal
ne an uns zum Ende, oder? Wir sind 8, 8, 8, 8. Moment, das ist 8, 8 oder 8, 8, 7? Bin grad
brain-dead. 8, oder? Wir sind 8, 8. Weil ich wollt grad sagen, so viel kommt ja gar nicht
mehr. Und es gibt auf Lunaris-Tempel auch nen Trick, den hab ich aber noch nicht kapiert,
woran man das erkennt. Man kann, im Lunaris-Tempel kann man erkennen, ob man richtig ist, anhand
von irgendwelchen Wagen. Ab hier, genau. Hier stehen jetzt irgendwelche Wagen rum und
anhand des Wagens kann man irgendwie erkennen, wo's lang geht. Das hab ich aber noch nicht
gecheckt, wie sich das genau verhält.
Okay, hier geht's auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht lang. Wo ist denn die andere Richtung?
Ja, und das kann man angeblich irgendwie an der Wagenplatzierung im Lunaris-Tempel erkennen,
ob man richtig ist oder nicht. Aber ich bin da zu low-brain für. Ich hab's noch nicht
kapiert, wie ich das richtig erkenne. Ah, hier geht's lang. Sonst müsste hier irgendwo
ein kleiner Portal sein. Ja, nice. Excellent. So, Boss-Baschen, der übrigens auch nichts
kann, wo wir wieder beim Thema sind. Ich mein, mein Boss-Damage zackt, aber für die reichts
grad noch so. Okay, ich hab nix gesagt. Ganz so sehr Facetanken geht dann doch nicht.
So, zack. Ähm, und jetzt, jetzt zurück. Statt. Äh, Einloggen, Lunaris, Discourse, runterrennen,
Hammer-Bridge, Boss, Act 9. Ich glaub, das passt jetzt. Äh, Lunaris, Discourse, runter jetzt,
dann Hammer-Bridge. Und jetzt die Gegner weg. Den Boss wegklatschen, Klei. Hier können wir
uns noch mal schön auf den Weg alles platt machen und Fett-XP. Ich, die Katzen-Micro-Transaction
gefällt mir. Generell, wenn irgendein Mobile-Entwickler wissen will, wie er von mir Geld kriegt, der
muss irgendwelche Katzen-Micro-Transactions einbauen, die kauf ich mir dann. Gut, nein,
auf, okay, auf Mobile nicht. Auf Mobile geb ich für den Crab kein Geld aus. Aber ich
hab's, ich hab sogar in BDO hab ich mir Katzen als Tiere gekauft, wobei Katzen in BDO gar
nicht gut waren als Pets. Catgirl, so sieht's aus. Der Boss ist auch richtig low-brain,
die kämpfen miteinander selbst anstatt mich zu bashen. Gleich kommt das beste Farm-Gebiet
im ganzen Spiel am Anfang. Da farmen sich auch die ganzen Streamer und Pros den Fingerwund
am Anfang von der Liga. Aber ich finde den Fight visuell sehr schön. Ja, es ist einer
der abwechslungsreichsten Fights, das stimmt. Also vor optisch, optisch schön gemacht,
ja. Sind wir denn eigentlich mal hier? Run-Speed. Run-Speed, immer Run-Speed. Kannste ja auch
die Catpets kaufen. Ja, genug, genug. Microtransaction-Points hab ich ja noch, ne? Pets. Äh, what? Moment,
die hab ich mir schon. Boah, ist der scheiß teuer. 26 Euro. What the hell? What the fuck?
Die Kraut, ne, das kauf ich mir nicht. Was haben wir hier sonst noch? Orange Cat. Sieht
fast aus wie meine, vor der Farbe her. Wobei meine ist halt, ne? Schwarz, weiß, rot. Demonica.
Samp, 27 Euro. What the hell, warum? Angel Samp. Die gefällt mir. Aber ich geb trotzdem
keine 27 Euro für aus. Das, ja, Eisenhower seh ich ähnlich, das ist mehr oder weniger
Donation an den Hersteller, das stimmt. Aber man muss ja, also man muss ja wirklich nicht
und das einzige, was man sich fast, fast kaufen muss sind ein paar Stashtabs, aber ansonsten
brauchst du ja nichts und es hat eines der besten Free-to-play-Games überhaupt, also
man kann das schon machen. So, das hier ist die Map, wo sich alle am Anfang der Liga
dumm und dusselig farmen, weil die vom Layout so simpel ist und man einfach nur grad auslaufen
muss, gut Loot kriegt und XP kriegt. Und wenn ich's jetzt richtig mach, farm ich hier sogar
ein paar Mal hoch und runter. Wobei es eigentlich umsonst ist, also lohnt sich nicht. Genau,
immer kann Tabula Rasa... Warum ist Delirium jetzt auf einmal fertig? Hab ich grad irgendwie
den Knopf aus Versehen gedrückt, um Delirium abzubrechen? Hä? Was, du bist ra... man kann
da rauslaufen? Wirklich? Man kann da ernsthaft rauslaufen? Äh, was ist eigentlich mit Sellout?
Warst du nicht am überlegen... Nein, das war ein Witz. Ich hab, wie jeder andere, hab
ich endlich auch mal ne Anfrage von Raid Shadow Legends bekommen. Nein, ich mach doch keine
Das ist echt bestes Gebiet hier für Farmer. Einfach sinnlos grad ausrennen und zeugsleveln.
Besser geht's nicht, ja. Ich renn da nochmal schnell durch. Da hab ich doch einmal in Skill
Gems noch nen Level. Äh, warum nicht... Moment, was ist die Frage? Warum nicht EatsMoney und
wenn du den Titel schreibst, schon eh nur Leute, die es sehen wollen. Ne, das will ich nicht
unterstützen. Crap. Die haben teilweise auch absolut, äh, fragwürdige Verträge. Also
ich mach seit YouTube schon so, dass ich eigentlich nur was mit Leuten zusammen mache, dass ich,
dass ich halbwegs vertreten kann und mir eventuell auch so in Erwägung ziehen würde. Das mit
Elgato war ja auch zum Beispiel hauptsächlich, weil ich selbst ne Capture Card von denen verwendet
hab und man kann sich dann halt schon, ähm, okay, das stimmt nicht. Ghost Recon Breakpoint
hab ich gemacht auf YouTube. Ähm, und mir war schon mehr oder weniger klar, dass das
Spiel sackt. Aber das war halt echt nice Angebot vom Money her, ja. Und keine shady Verträge
wie bei, ähm, Raid Shadow Legends. Wenn die mir 10k anbieten, ja für 10k, okay, für
10k würd ich's mir wahrscheinlich auch überlegen, aber ganz so viel ist es nicht. Ich weiß,
ich hab's euch ja mal gesagt im Stream, ich weiß es nicht mehr, was es war. Ich guck
mal, ich guck mal nach, was die angeboten haben. Ich glaub 700€ oder sowas. Was halt
echt für so ein Mini-Stream wie meiner voll der Witz ist, ne. Auf YouTube hätt ich's
verstehen können, vor allem wenn ich mal wieder einen aktiven Monat erwischt hab. Auf YouTube
gucken sie ja auch 35 bis 50.000 oder so. Oder, ja gut, Promotions vielleicht weniger.
Sagen wir mal, auf YouTube gucken sie 15 bis 50, je nachdem, wie der Algorithmus mitmacht.
Ähm, ich guck mal kurz nach, was die angeboten haben. Und dann cacken wir mal. Cack W'n wir
mal kurz drüber. Raid. Äh, Raid? Moment, wo sind die denn jetzt? Oje, da bin ich mal
da. Wo sind die denn? Ich krieg jede Menge Werbung. Final Fantasy Werbung, Raid Shadow
Legends. Raid wants to sponsor one of your videos. Ne, ich muss noch Wupplors suchen.
Fuck, ich find's nicht. Oder war ich so doof und hab das gelöscht? Moment, ich sag's
euch gleich, wo hab ich geschäftliche Anfall? Sponsoring. Ist halt so viel Müll dabei. Kritische
Sicherheitswarnung. Okay, das ist irgendein Spam. Sponsorangebot. Hier. Ähm, ne, das
ist, noch mal, die haben noch mal geschrieben, lull. Die haben noch mal geschrieben, das
hab ich ja noch gar nicht gesehen. Also, was die hier anbieten ist, ich mein, ich bin
ein richtig kleiner Furztream. Ich hab, normalerweise, wenn ich jetzt nicht grad Pest of Hacks anmache,
was soll ich sonst machen? Hab ich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, sag mal, so über Daumen gepeilt,
180, 200, 220, was auch immer, je nach Tag. Viewer, passt mal auf. Grund, Grundgehalt,
Grundgehalt, nennen sie das, ja. 425 Dollar Bonus für je, boah, ist das krass, Alter.
Für 90 Downloads, 1500 Dollar. Für 90 Downloads. Also, wenn ich euch jetzt alle beschwätze
und ich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ein Riesen-Streamer wäre und ich krieg, keine Ahnung, 900, 900
Downloads oder so vornein, dann krieg ich fucking 15.000 Dollar. Nein, nein, nein, das
war ich nicht, war ich nicht, aber trotzdem, what the hell, aber das war nicht das ursprüngliche
Angebot. Das war nicht das ursprüngliche Angebot, aber irgendwie find ichs grade nicht.
Aber in die Richtung gehts, ne, Leute, also in die. Ich find's, ich find das andere wirklich
nicht. Ist auch egal. Aber da seht ihr mal, was da für Kohle im Spiel ist, Alter. 15.000
Euro für 900 Downloads oder halt 1500 für 90. What the fuck. Das ist ja, das ist doch
nicht normal. Das ist, also, ich mein, ich kanns ja gar keinem übel nehmen, wenn er
den Scheiß mitmacht. I-Lo, 1-7-0-6-5-Monat-Dankeschön, Big Brain Subscription. Danke schön für
den Sub, huge. Aber das ist halt wirklich, äh, kein Wunder, dass die Leute das machen,
bei so viel Kohle. Und jetzt überlegt euch mal im umgekehrten Fall, das lohnt sich für
den Anbieter. Also das bedeutet ja im Endeffekt, die können die scheißen Geld. Und letztendlich
kommt das Geld von denjenigen, die die Mobile Games spielen. Das muss sich ja für die
lohnen. Wenn die sich das nicht für die lohnen würde, dann würden die nicht jetzt schon
seit zwei Jahren Raid Shadow Legends dich überall vollspammen. Und das waren die Konditionen
für mich als Popel-Streamer. Auf YouTube hätten die deutlich mehr geboten und jetzt könnt
ihr euch dreimal überlegen, was du da teilweise für Angebote kriegst, wenn ihr da mehrere
tausend Leute zugucken. Da gehts richtig ab. Oh ja, genau, überlegt mal, wie viele Leute
im Cash Shop Sachen ausgeben müssen, dass sich das lohnt. Aber es muss sich lohnen,
sonst würden sie es nicht machen. Hallo, sterben please, Mops. Heftig, oder? So, Skill-Punkte,
das haben wir. Das Large Sockel können wir noch skillen. Was brauchen wir sonst noch?
Life Points, das, das. Kann man ansonsten noch Speck, Increased Area Damage, Sekunde mal
Passive Building rein lurken. Das ist falsch übrigens. Oh, das ist nice. Das gibt mehr
Movement Speed, ne? PoE Elusive, das gibt mehr Movement Speed. Nice. Das gönnen wir
uns jetzt noch mal. Ich muss noch was ausprobieren. Kann man, wenn man Control drückt, ne, geht
nicht. Highly Optimized Skill Tree, null W. Aber ist schon heftig, was die für Kohle
rausrücken, oder? Wahnsinn. Ok, jetzt muss ich mal kurz in mich gehen. Was muss ich denn
jetzt machen? Blood Accord Dark Summer gemacht. Ich muss noch mal zurück in die anderen Acts,
das hab ich schon abgeholt, ne? Irgendwelche Rewards abholen? Keine Ahnung. Hab ich nämlich
ganz vergessen. Ich hab den Punkt nicht Respeckt, ich hab vorher gar nicht gespeckt. Achso,
doch, doch, du hast recht. Ja, den Punkt hab ich wirklich mal Respeckt, ganz am Anfang.
Was sagst du, dass du das mal weißt, oder? Lull. Braucht ihr irgendwas von? Alles M-Memory
was? So. Jetzt geht's weiter. Kann man noch weiter specken. Ok, ähm, also ich muss jetzt...
Weißt du was, was wir machen können? Ich seh grad, hier hab ich Flame Dash. Ich könnte
noch einen Second Wind in Flame Dash machen, ne? Wollen wir noch schnell. Ich glaub, wenn
man Second Wind in Flame Dash hat, dann ist der Cooldown kürzer. Second Wind. Glaubst
du, was macht den Cooldown? Für Flame Dash? Niedriger. Ups. So, ähm, wenn ich jetzt richtig
liege, muss man hochlaufen und durch die Wüste. Ja, ziemlich sicher. Man muss nicht mit den
WCs reden. Overrated. Einer, Beast. Haha, Beast. You will be captured.
It's down. Huge Crap. So, ich renn jetzt hier mal ein bisschen durch. Moment, da unten
geht's lang. So, jetzt musste ich in die Wüste dort diese, äh, Quest mit dem Schwert machen,
mit diesem Sandsturm. Und den Skorpion killen für Skillpoint. Ich denk nur ein bisschen
laut vor mich hin wieder. Mich wunderts eigentlich, dass sie ne Wüste in dem Spiel eingebaut haben
und nicht noch irgendeine Stadt in die Wüste gebastelt haben. Weil ansonsten ist ja in dem
Spiel alles dabei. Dschungelwelt, Eiswelt, ähm, keine Ahnung, Underground, Geschichten,
Kumpf, aber irgendwie ne Wüste fehlt. Und die Wüste ist irgendwie nur eine Karte ohne
was dabei. Also, hätte man so richtig low effort noch ne Stadt basteln können. Mit
noch ner Quest oder so. Aber ich will mich jetzt nicht beschweren, weil da müsste ich
noch mehr Kampagne machen. Aber das muss ja nicht sein. So, jetzt muss ich hier, irgendwo
hier ist ne Kiste und dann muss ich die Kistenquest machen. Pff, hab ich genug. Also Tier 1 Maps
hab ich genug, die muss ich nicht aufheben. Ich finde es komisch, also die Akt 1 bis 4,
vielleicht auch noch 5 ist irgendwie einprägsamer als Akt 6 bis 10. Akt 6 bis 10 ist irgendwie
so, so einprägsloses Durchrushen. Wenn ihr wisst was ich meine. Genau, die Kiste muss
ich jetzt machen. Das Ding will mir unbedingt Tropical Island Maps aufschwätzen. Ähm,
ich glaub man ist einfach zu stark auf den Punkt, kann sein. Irgendjemand hat gerade
im Chat geschrieben, wo war das denn hier, ich gönne jedem Streamer das Geld, muss doch
jeder selber wissen ob er sich den Quatsch runterlädt oder nicht. Dem zweiten Teil würde
ich zustimmen, allerdings dem ersten Teil, und das sag ich als jemand der selbst seit
10 Jahren YouTube macht und auch die ein oder anderen Werbedinger schon gemacht hat, jetzt
auf Twitch nicht, auf Twitch gucken auch zu wenige. Ich finde das Verhältnis teilweise
nicht gerechtfertigt. Ich weiß jetzt kommen die ersten an und sag, ja Max so ist das aber,
Kapitalismus, Markt und sonst was. Aber ich finde manchmal das Verhältnis nicht gerechtfertigt.
Wenn ich mir überlege, es gibt Leute die arbeiten sagen wir mal im Krankenhaus oder
sonst wo, und die verdienen ein Apfel und ein Ei und ich setz mich auf YouTube hin und
sag ho, das ist das neue Ghost Recon und krieg dann irgendwie, weiß nicht was das war, irgendwas
vierstelliges, null. Also das finde ich irgendwie nicht gerechtfertigt. Was es nicht heißen
soll, dass man den YouTube Leuten weniger Geld geben muss, man könnte den im Krankenhaus
einfach mehr bezahlen. By the way, was mache ich hier eigentlich gerade? Ich renn falsch,
ich muss in die Stadt, muss in die Stadt, muss dahin, wo war ich denn hier, Schwachsinn,
muss hier hin und in die Stadt. Kannste da ein Geld spenden gehen? Ich hab sogar teilweise
Geld davon gespendet, nicht von allem und nicht immer, aber bei manchen Sachen. Ne,
ich muss mit dem Pärchen reden, mit Sin und dann wieder mit dem Pärchen, genau. Das ist,
gar nicht mal, wegen den plus eins Lightning Skills kann man das sogar halbwegs zählen.
Also das mit 10 Chaos halte ich für ein bisschen übertrieben. Komm, ich mach das mal in mein
Stash für 5 Chaos rein, falls überhaupt, aber das ist viel zu low. So, los mal zurück.
Jetzt kommen wir hier auf und den Skorpion bashen. Ja, also wie gesagt, ich gönn das
prinzipiell den Leuten schon. Okay, nicht allen, das gibt ein paar Spaß in die Magie
nicht, aber das ist jetzt ein anderes Thema. Aber ich find das verhältnis teilweise, was
du Geld für Promotion kriegst. Und wie gesagt, ich bin ja auf YouTube jetzt mit 270k und
ein paar zehntausende Aufrufe pro Video jetzt auch nicht wahnsinnig groß. Ich will nicht
wissen, was jemand kriegt. Wir müssen jetzt ja nicht von Leuten wie Pewdiepie anfangen
oder so. Was nur, was jemand kriegt, wie, nehmen wir mal, wer ist denn in Deutschland,
Skorpion oder so oder Kronk oder so. Da ist Kohle drin, das finde ich vom Verhältnis
nicht mehr gerechtfertigt. Wie gesagt, mir geht es nicht so sehr darum, dass die Leute
da auf YouTube zu viel für kriegen, aber ich finde es halt einfach im Verhältnis zu
dem, was Leute, die wirklich tagtäglich schwerste Arbeit somit auch für die Allgemeinheit verrichten
zu kriegen, finde ich das Verhältnis nicht passend. Habt ihr einen Scam Shop Typ im anderen
Steam gefunden? Echt? Und was wollt ihr auch, dass die Leute ihn grüßen? Moment, das ist
auch falsch. Wo ist denn hier der Eingang zum Skorpion, Alter? Selbe Diskussion über
Fußballern. Naja, ich finde, bei Fußballern ist es noch ein bisschen was anderes. Ich
meine, klar, ein Fußballer muss leben davon, aber auf der anderen Seite, man darf auch
nicht vergessen, Fußballer, die viel absahen, sind ja wirklich auch nur die Top-Spieler
in Top-Vereinen. Also du musst quasi dein ganzes Leben mehr oder weniger der Sache da
verschrieben haben und auch talentmäßig und einsatzmäßig zu den Besten der Welt gehören,
dass du dort richtig Geld machen kannst. Ich finde, das ist noch ein bisschen was anderes,
als wenn irgendwelche 0-8-15-Reaction-Influencer-Leute da am Start sind. Also als Fußballer musst
ja wirklich richtig was können und zu den Besten der Welt zählen irgendwo. Klar, im
Prinzip geht die Diskussion in die gleiche Richtung, da hast du schon recht, aber allgemein
finde ich einfach, dass die Leute, die im Krankenhaus arbeiten oder auch in der Altenpflege
oder gibt zig Berufe, nimm einfach mal den Typ, der die Straße teert bei 36 Grad draußen,
dass die einmal zu wenig Anerkennung dafür kriegen und auch zu wenig Geld. Und der größte
Witz überhaupt war ja, als sie jetzt gesagt haben, bei der ganzen Corona-Geschichte, dass
so nach dem Motto, oh, unsere Helden im Krankenhaus und sowas. Und vielleicht, Alter, das Viech
ist fast tot. Vielleicht könnt ihr euch noch damals dran erinnern, ich hab damals im Stream
gesagt, ich wette mit euch, wenn Corona vorbei ist oder nicht mehr so akut, es erinnert sich
keiner mehr an die angeblichen Helden. Vor allem nicht, wenn man sich vorstellt, es wird
mal dort einer arbeitslos und das wird ihm niemals jemand danken. Niemals wird es zudem
sagen, oh, ich sehe hier Frau Müller, keine Ahnung, sie sind jetzt arbeitslos, noch 2
Jahre bis zur Rente, aber ich sehe, sie waren während der Corona-Krise quasi Tag 1, Tag
2 im Krankenhaus, wir kommen ihnen jetzt ein bisschen entgegen, never, wirst du ihm Leben
nicht sehen, wird nicht passieren. Es wird komplett auf die Leute geschissen im Endeffekt.
So, äh, wie komme ich denn jetzt hier raus? Ist hier kein Ausgang? Kein Ausgang. So, nu
muss ich zurück. Desert und Foothills. Foothills müsste oben sein. Ich glaube, man versteht
was ich meine. Natürlich ist mir klar, warum das so ist, wie es ist und warum die Leute
so viel Geld kriegen für eigentlich was Banales. Ich meine es nicht die Fußballspieler, ich
meine beispielsweise irgendwelche YouTube-Reaction-Influencer oder so. Ist mir schon klar, warum, weil es sich
letztendlich rentiert für die Leute, die das machen. Aber trotzdem finde ich das vom
Verhältnis her nicht gerechtfertigt. Ja. So, jetzt müssen wir nach rechts oben, genau,
Boiling Lake und dieses Medusa-Ding killen. Und dazu kommt auch noch, jetzt habe ich mich
jetzt nur über quasi Berufe ausgelassen, die meiner Meinung nach viel für die Allgemeinheit
machen und nicht die notwendige Beachtung bzw. Geld kriegen. Dazu kommt ja noch, dass generell
in Deutschland kaum jemand in der Bevölkerung teil hat am eigentlichen, nennen wir es mal,
Reichtum. Wenn man sich, oh fuck, das Ding versteinert ein. Wenn man sich überlegt,
dass wir seit einer ganzen Weile jetzt schon zu den Ländern gehören, wo die Schere zwischen
Arm und Reich mit am größten ist. Natürlich, wir sind nicht auf Platz 1, geht immer noch,
geht immer noch mehr. Und dass kaum die Durchschnittsleute in Deutschland kaum wirklich Vermögen haben
und auch nicht in der Lage sind, quasi Vermögen aufzubauen, sodass sie ein bisschen unabhängig
sind, dass die Leute im Endeffekt nichts von abhaben, wenn nicht auch nicht gerechtfertigt
so. Ich kann mich nicht beschweren, ja. Also, ich bin eigentlich gerade der, der sich freuen
müsste über das, wie es läuft. Ich verdiene auf der einen Seite jobmäßig genug Geld,
ich könnte nebenbei mit YouTube Geld verdienen. Ich verdiene mit, seit Jahren dadurch, dass
ich genug AdSense Links gespendet habe, gespendet habe mit AdSense. Ich kriege sogar mittlerweile
auf Twitch ganz, ganz gute, ganz gute Subzahlen. Vom eigentlichen Job an sich verdiene ich
auch was. Ich habe dann Haus am Start mit 35. Also, ich dürfte mich da eigentlich gar
nicht drüber beschweren großartig. An Roste finde ich das ungerecht verteilt. Ich könnte
eigentlich sagen, ja, ist doch geil. Gib mir noch mehr. Der Tainter supportet genau. Nee,
trotzdem. Und ich habe das jetzt auch vor, auch im YouTube Video schon von einigen gesehen.
Wenn es Interviews gab mit Leute, mit Leuten, die halt richtig Massive-Kohle haben, die sprechen
genau das gleiche an. Guckst du dir beispielsweise mal, da sind wir in Dänemark an. In Dänemark
ist das nicht so. In Dänemark bezahlen auch extrem viel Steuern und Abgaben. Aber da
sieht es auch gesundheitssystemmäßig und Kindergartenplätze mäßig, um nur ein paar
Beispiele zu sehen, viel besser aus als bei uns. So, erstmal hier raus und jetzt muss
der Tunnel hoch. Das ist halt eine Verteilung, die empfinde ich rein vom Betrachten der Zahlen
als ungerecht. Ich sage nicht, dass man Leuten, die nichts machen und eigentlich nur Kohle
abgreifen wollen, fördern sollte. Aber mir geht es ja gerade um Leute, die tagtäglich
was machen und kaum über die Runden kommen. Wenn du dir überlegst, dass, ich glaube 40%
in Deutschland, das gibt es letztens beim Spiegel, da gab es da wieder schöne Grafik
für, fällt mir jetzt noch keiner ein, ich bin kein großer Spiegel-Fan, dass 40% quasi
vom Monatsgehalt, wie sagt man, von der Hand in den Mund leben, also sprich, die kommen
mehr oder weniger plus minus null raus mit ihrem Monatsgehalt. Also die haben nichts
im Endeffekt. Die haben ihren Monatsgehalt, aber das geht komplett drauf für Wohnung,
Essen, Verpflegung, was auch immer es da alles gibt. Die haben nichts übrig, um sich
irgendetwas aufzubauen. Die leben vom Monatsgehalt, ich glaube 40% waren das. Das ist übelst
viel, wenn man sich mal überlegt, dass auf der einen Seite feiern wir uns immer so ab,
so nach dem Motto, Alter, Deutschland hat so wahnsinnig viel Geld, dass das alles mehr
Schein als sein ist und gar nichts stimmt für mindestens 50% der Bevölkerung, hat man
ja an dem ganzen Corona-Thema gesehen. Davor haben sich alle abgefeiert, Deutschland ist
so reich, so reich, sie haben zwar gedacht, okay, also mein Monatsgehalt spiegelt sich
nicht wirklich wieder, aber wir haben so reich, wir sind so reich, wir haben so viel Geld und
dann kam Corona und auf einmal innerhalb von zwei Monaten sind wir von, oh, wir sind so
reich, wir können im Endeffekt, was weiß ich, die halbe Welt mit bezahlen und das und
hier und jenes machen, zu fuck, wir sind pleite. Das ging innerhalb von zwei Monaten. Ihr wisst
euch mal, auch wenn ihr euch mal die News anguckt, so davor, Alter, sind wir reich, haben wir
Geld und auch alle Leute so, ja, uns geht es richtig gut, zwei Monate Corona, fuck, wir
sind pleite. So von 100 auf Null und ich glaube, das lag daran, dass vorher schon keiner Geld
hatte, im eigenen Portemonnaie wohlgemerkt und im eigenen Vermögen und durch Corona
ihn jetzt so richtig aufgefallen ist, weil viele auch noch arbeitslos geworden sind,
viele Kurzarbeit machen müssen, so nach dem Motto, fuck, es ist nicht nur mein Gehalt,
es ist im Prinzip überall und ja, natürlich sind wir reich, haben Geld, allerdings die
Frage, wo das ist und nicht im Vermögen bei 50, 60 Prozent der Bevölkerung. Also wir
haben kein Geld in dem Sinn, dass man sagen könnte, ja, jeder in Deutschland hat im Durchschnitt
so wahnsinnig viel Geld, das ist gar nicht so. Ja, habe ich irgendwas vergessen zu machen?
Ich glaube nicht, ich glaube, ich muss jetzt hier noch einen Boss killen, aber ich finde
gerade bei Corona ist es voll ins Auge gesprungen, das Ganze, dass diese ganze Selbstwahrnehmung,
die viele Leute hatten, dass wir so viel Geld haben, gar nicht stimmt. Wir, also der überwiegende
Teil der Bevölkerung hat keine viel, hat nicht viel Kohle und ich habe von ein paar
Leuten als Antwort darauf gekriegt, wenn ich das gesagt habe, so nach dem Motto, ja, doch
uns geht's ja alle gut, wir müssen nicht hungern. Ich weiß nicht, ob das der richtige Anspruch
ist, ganz ehrlich, als viertgrößte Wirtschaftsmacht, nee, wie nennt man das, als viertgrößte Volkswirtschaft
der Welt, tritt größer, ich glaube, viertgrößte, was unbedingt, China, USA, Japan und dann
kommen wir, glaube ich. Alles Müll. Ja, viertgrößte, so und als viertgrößte
Wirtschafts der Welt ist es ganz schön braindead zu sagen, uns geht's ja so gut, weil wir nicht
hungern müssen. Also, das ist doch nicht der Anspruch, den man da haben müsste. Korea
hat K-Pop richtig, ansonsten steht Korea auch nicht so schlecht da. Also den Vergleich konnte
ich da nicht so ganz nachvollziehen. Moment, ich bin falsch, da muss ich gar nicht hin,
ich muss erstmal den Boss bashen. Irgendwo müsste hier noch ein Boss sein, den ich killen
muss. Am Rand der Map. Wo ist er? Da. Bashen, alter, bashen. Ist das jetzt dein Feierbild?
Nee. Ich spiele bis 75 oder so und dann kauf ich mir Gear für Castle & Creed Frost Nova,
Ice Nova, Frost Nova ist Diablo, ich bring es immer durcheinander. Die Waffen habe ich
schon, aber ich brauche den Rest noch, aber ich habe ein bisschen Budget und ich level
einfach Spellslinger, weil es mega Bock macht zu leveln und weil es total easy ist zu leveln.
Oh, sehr gut. Boss, verrecken please. Spellslinger ist ja nice, ja. Es macht übel Spaß zu leveln.
Der Boss ist ätzender. Ich mache ja auch kaum Damage auf Bosse. So, jetzt haben wir es,
sehr gut. So, und jetzt zurück und die andere Map. Also ich muss sagen, Spellslinger ist,
es gibt ja erst zwei Patches oder so. Zwei oder drei. Drei. Drei. Drei Leaks oder so.
Das gibt es ja noch nicht so lang. Das ist der spaßigste Weg zu leveln, den sie sich
bisher ausgedacht haben. Ist ultra nice. Taugt eigentlich die iPhone Ladekabel vom
Chinaman was klar. Zumal es nur USB ist, kannst du das auch relativ bedenkenlos machen. Ich
habe, bis auf das iPhone Ladekabel was dabei war, ich habe nur Schiene Adapter. Und das
schlimmste ist, also das größte Schiene Adapter Paket, was ich habe, ich habe mir ein 50er
Pack USB Kabel gekauft bei AliExpress und nicht einfach nur USB Kabel, ein Meter oder
zwei Meter, ein Meter, zwei Meter, 1,50, vielleicht sogar 1,50. Also ein Meter wäre ein bisschen
kurz. Ich sage jetzt einfach mal zwei Meter USB Kabel, 50 Stück mit USB auf Mikro USB
inklusive USB C. Und jetzt ratet mal was das gekostet hat. Wo wir gerade auch wieder bei
Schiene Adapter sind. Jetzt ratet mal was das gekostet hat. 50 USB Kabel, zwei Meter
Mikro USB, USB C in einem. Na gut 10 Euro. Leute ich rede für 50 Kabel zusammen, nicht
für pro Kabel. Inklusive Versand wohlgemerkt. So ungefähr 45 Euro. Ungefähr 45 Euro.
Ich meine 45 Euro, überleg mal, das ist oder oder oder oder 42 Euro oder so. Überleg
mal, das ist weniger als ein Euro pro USB Kabel, inklusive Versand aus China. Wofür
braucht man 50 haben? Haben. Ich wollte einfach nie wieder USB Kabel suchen müssen. Und das
hat sich gelohnt. Seitdem ich die Kiste habe, immer wenn ich einen USB Kabel brauche, zack,
USB Kabel am Start. So haben ist besser als brauchen. Leritz sagt es gerade haben ist
besser als brauchen. So sieht es aus. Exzellent. Magst du der USB Reseller? Deswegen ist es
ja auch gerade so beliebt, dass man Dropshipping macht. In Deutschland, ich weiß gar nicht
ob Dropshipping in Deutschland so beliebt ist. Wisst ihr was Dropshipping ist? Chat. Big
Brain Chat. Chat weiß sowas. Dropshipping ist, wenn du verkaufst als sagen wir mal deutscher
Shop, allerdings in Wirklichkeit die Bestellung nur nach China weiterleitest und die liefern
direkt an den, der bestellt hat. Du vermittelst im Endeffekt nur. Du bist ein deutscher Shop
und du vermittelst quasi Aufträge nach China, wenn du so willst. Letztendlich sieht es
für die Leute ein bisschen so aus, als kaufen die bei dir, aber unterm Strich leitest du
den Auftrag weiter nach China und die Chinesen beliefern die Leute auch direkt. Also im Endeffekt
ist es eigentlich eine ziemlich Big Brain Geschichte, weil du brauchst halt nichts. Du brauchst
kein Lager, du brauchst keine Logistik, du brauchst nichts. Du brauchst nichts. Du musst
einfach nur eine gute Webseite machen und gucken, dass die in Google gut platziert ist.
Das ist Dropshipping. Was bringt eigentlich dieser Unset Ring? Ultracrap. Du hast schonmal
überlegt das zu machen. Warum nicht? Es ist so gut wie kein Risiko bei im Endeffekt.
Also meine Erfahrungen mit China Shops sind ja allgemein ziemlich gut. Also ich hatte
schon Probleme mit Shops, wo ich über Paypal bezahlt habe und Paypal hatte dieses Support-Programm,
ich weiß gar nicht wie es heißt. Also sprich, wenn der Shop nicht liefert oder wenn der
Shop Müll liefert oder wenn der Shop nicht auf Rücksendegeschiss reagiert, kannst du
einen Dispute aufmachen bei Paypal und die schreiben dann den Shop an und dann kann der
Shop Stellung nehmen und wenn der Shop nicht antwortet, kriegst du das Geld wieder und
so wird es quasi zurückgebucht von denen. Und das war ein Riesenakt. Ich habe mir mal
einen Server-Rack bestellt und im Endeffekt kam das an mit zerbrochener Tür. Und ich
habe den Shop angeschrieben, das war bei CrowdFox, hießen die, CrowdFox. Ich weiß gar nicht,
ich habe dieses übelste Crap-Seite. Der Typ sieht aus wie ein Charakter, der Microtransactions
nicht richtig ausgerüstet hat. Oh ja, CrowdFox, da bestelle ich auch nie wieder was hier,
das da. Ja, habe ich mir bestellt und kam halt mit zerbrochener Tür an. Der Marktplatz
für schlaue Online-Shopper, also sozusagen Five-Hat-Shopping. Und dann habe ich ewig
mit denen rummachen müssen. Leute, ich merke es im Hals, dass ich heute 8 Stunden schon
auf Twitch bin oder so. Da habe ich ewig mit denen rummachen müssen. Also erstmal habe
ich denen gesagt, Jungs, kaputt, zurückschicken oder neu schicken, mir egal, haben sich nicht
gerührt. Sie haben nur gesagt, ja, wir haben ihre Mail bekommen. Nicht gerührt, nicht
gerührt. Da habe ich bei PayPal so einen Dispute aufgemacht, nicht gerührt, nicht gerührt,
nicht gerührt, hin und her, Screenshots gemacht, also Fotos gemacht, geschrieben und die haben
sich dann am letzten Tag gemeldet. China-Shop, also ich musste da quasi zwei Monate warten
und Dinge unternehmen. So, AliExpress, gleiche gehabt. Also AliExpress ist mit der bekannteste
China-Shop bei AliExpress bestellt. Ich habe einen Tracking-Link bekommen, der nicht funktioniert
hat, habe ein paar Tage gewartet, habe den Shop angeschrieben. Der Shop meint, ah, dauert
noch ein bisschen und ah, Tracking-Link, sie schickt mir einen neuen Tracking-Link. So,
Tracking-Link war exakt der gleiche, den sie mir geschickt haben, der das letzte Mal schon
nicht funktioniert hat und nichts angekommen ist. Habe ich bei AliExpress einen Fall aufgemacht,
habe das kurz reingeschrieben und ich glaube, man musste noch nicht mal was schreiben, man
konnte schon den vorgefertigten Gründen auswählen, so nach dem Motto Tracking-Link invalid, Delivery
not Arriving, irgendwie sowas. Und dann, was dort war, ist umgedreht bei AliExpress. Der
Shop musste quasi irgendwie belegen, dass er das alles richtig gemacht hat und wenn
ich nicht innerhalb von einem Tag mein Okay gebe, dass der Shop jetzt seine Arbeit richtig
gemacht hat, kriege ich automatisch das Geld wieder. Das ist genau umgedreht, umgedreht
gewesen bei AliExpress. So und ich habe dann einen halben Tag nicht reagiert, weil auch
Zeitzone und sowas und zack hatte ich irgendwie meine 35 Euro wieder. Ich musste überhaupt
nichts machen. Also, damit muss ich sagen, da ist AliExpress schon vor Paypal oder allem
anderen. So wie es eigentlich auch sein soll. Kommt drauf an, wenn du fragst, wenn natürlich
ein Händler fragst nicht, frag mal Hardware-Rat, der wird abkotzen oder sowas. Aber ich als
Kunde finde ich es natürlich gut. Aber so muss es sein. Ich habe bisher nur gute Erfahrungen
mit AliExpress gemacht. Und obwohl ich während Corona diese USB-Schalter bestellt habe,
die sind auch, sogar die sind mittlerweile angekommen. Ich wurde noch nie so richtig
scammast von einem China-Shop und hatte dann keine Möglichkeit, irgendwas dagegen zu machen.
Also richtig pock. Im Gegensatz, also ich wurde mehr gescampt, ganz ehrlich, ich wurde mehr
gescampt von Offline-Läden bei uns, von Deutschen, also von hier EU, UK und DE-Shops. Nicht gescampt
im eigentlichen Sinne halt, wo ich etwas unzufrieden war, als bei China-Shops. Bei China-Shops
weißt du, worauf du dich einlässt. Also wenn du bei China-Shops zum Beispiel jetzt, keine
Ahnung, irgendjemand kauft bei China, wird in einem China-Shop, das macht eine Syndicate
hier drin. Also wenn du im China-Shop jetzt mal billig gesagt, wenn du im China-Shop
Unterhosen kaufst. So. Und du kriegst dann 50 Unterhosen für 20 Euro, jetzt mal übertrieben,
oder? Und die Unterhosen gehen halt nach einmal falsch draufgetreten kaputt. Du weißt,
was du kriegst, ja? Und da bist du auch nicht enttäuscht, weil du hast ja auch im Prinzip
absolut Minimum bezahlt. Ups. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn du hier in den Shop gehst und
die verkaufen dir China-Kram und preisen es als best ever an und es ist nichts. Also die
negativste Erfahrung, die ich mal, weil ich gerade beim Thema Unterhosen war, gemacht
hab, ist, ich hab mir ne Packung bestellt, Kevin Klein Unterhosen und Hugo Boss Unterhosen.
Das war noch die Zeit, da war Hugo Boss cooler, Hugo Boss Unterhosen, Alter, huge nice. Mittlerweile
juckt es kein mehr. Und ihr wisst ja, ich bin auch nicht der bodenbewussteste, aber
ich wollt mir mal gescheite Unterhosen kaufen. So, hab ich mir gekauft und nach dem ersten
mal waschen, hat sich der Gummi gelöst, bei irgendwie 20-30% der Unterhosen, hat sich
der Gummi gelöst vom Stoff. Also quasi der Bund vom Stoff. The fuck? Ich mein, kostet
eine Unterhose, für das was da eine Unterhose kostet, kriegst du bei AliExpress 30 Unterhosen.
Hey, vielleicht übertrieben, 5 Unterhosen oder 10 und 10 Unterhosen. Also ich hab bisher
nur gute Erfahrungen mit China Shops gemacht. Gut, als Kunde, ja, sagen wir mal so, von
den Arbeitsbedingungen her ist Marktes was anderes sein, wobei man halt gerade bei den
Klamottenläden sagen muss, ob du jetzt Markenklamotten kaufst oder nicht, letztendlich kommen die
aus der gleichen Bangladesch-Fabrik wie die Dinger von AliExpress oder aus der gleichen
nordkoreanischen Nähfabrik. Das ist ja der neueste Trend, dass in China viele jetzt ein
bisschen gehobene Lebensstandard haben und die auch die allergrößten Scheiß-Shops nicht
mehr machen müssen. Jetzt müssen die Nordkoreaner die Scheiß-Shops machen, die quasi gesundheitsgefährden
sind und lebensgefährlich, gesundheitsgefährlich, kein Geld kriegen und lebenserwartungsverkürzende
Jobs quasi. Muss jetzt die Nordkoreaner machen zum Teil. Es trifft halt immer die Schwächsten
im Endeffekt bei sowas. Weiß gar nicht wie ich da jetzt drauf gekommen bin, aber rein
als Kunde. Übrigens hier, wir sehen jetzt zum vierten Mal den gleichen Boss. Na ein
nice Recycling. Haben wir alles an, das müssen wir noch machen. Gleich noch was gescheites
wecken. Aber der ist jetzt weiß. Ja, da hat Crying Gear Games schon mal richtig zugeschlagen.
Sie haben ihn durchsichtig gemacht. Poggers. Oh, alsch.
ich muss die Dinger hier killen. Tick. Wenn du die Curse Tote auf dem Weg zum
Boss machst, echt gut zu wissen. Und jetzt, als wäre es noch nicht genug Recycling gewesen,
jetzt kommen die Bosse nochmal. Ok, das ist jetzt unfair. Der nächste Encounter ist sogar
halbwegs neu. Der nächste Encounter sind alle diese Bosse in einem Boss. Also technisch
gesehen kommen die Bosse fünfmal dran. Mit Maps sechsmal oder so. Äh, hallo. Ok, ich
kann das Fisch jetzt mal bitte sterben. Au, au. Ich hab kein Life mehr. Nein. Oh, jetzt
gerade noch auf letzten Drücker. Jetzt ist Fisch gleich down. Mal sterben please Boss.
Jawoll. Jetzt ist er down. Da geht er down. So, letzter Act. Äh, nein, nein, nein. Letzter
Act. So, jetzt muss ich noch Skillbooks abholen, aber erstmal sellen. Das weg, das weg, äh.
Ist der was? Vielleicht wenn ich mal was anderes level noch. Gar nicht so übel. Blablablabla.
Da. Erstmal das weg, den Rest schmeißen, Stash. Kein Bock mehr jetzt anzugucken, aber
jetzt wahrscheinlich eh nur Müll. Beim Level kriegt man eh nix gescheitzt. Zu 90%. So,
ich muss noch Skillbücher holen. Aus dem letzten Act. Ach, cool, mal wieder Pässe
wechseln. Ja, gestern auch schon. Ich will mir unbedingt noch einen neuen Char machen,
dieses äh, diese League. So. Wo gibt's hier was? Wo gab's hier noch? Ah, hier, da. Ja,
zack, zack. 8 Punkte. Ich glaub, mehr gibt's hier nicht mehr. Gab's hier noch irgendwas?
Nee, ich glaub net. Oh ja, Passives. Nope, haben alles. Du bist durch mit Chars? Ja,
ich hab nicht so viel gespielt, aber ähm, den Headhunter Farmen, da komm ich wahrscheinlich
die League auch nicht mehr hin. So, jetzt muss man erstmal den komischen Templar Dude
hier oben retten. Ach, die Bosse werden übrigens später auf der Map auch nochmal recycelt.
So, mal gucken, ob ich's jetzt richtig zusammen krieg. Act 10 hab ich insgesamt, glaub, bisher
am wenigsten gemacht. Ich lauf jetzt hier runter, bis ich von der Map runter, also bis
ich hier aus der Map rauskomme. Äh, dann kill ich nochmal den Boss von Act 5, oder
was das war. Der jetzt reassembled ist. Das ist schon der 10. Act, ja. Der jetzt reassembled
ist und dann mach ich noch zwei Skillpoint-Quests und dann bin ich durch. Da kill ich Kitava
und dann bin ich fertig mit der Kampagne. Genau, eigentlich. Komm, für mich als Kacknoob
8 Stunden ist doch okay. Ich mein, ihr weißt, der Weltrekord liegt bei 330, aber die Leute
sind dann auch massiv gut. 330 Solo, ja. Der hat übrigens auch Chaos Bellslinger gespielt.
Der Weltrekord. Das war Solo. Jaja, Solo. Äh, Moment, wollen wir überhaupt kurz weg.
Warte mal, was, warte mal, was muss ich jetzt machen? Ich muss jetzt Control Blocks. Warte
mal, ich brauche erstmal den Waypoint. Der Waypoint ist doch hier oben irgendwo, ne? Wo
ist der Waypoint? Gab es überhaupt noch Waypoint? Muss es einen Waypoint geben. Ja, und, und
das ist noch ohne Level Gear, jaja, ich weiß. Deswegen, die Typen sind echt gut. Ich muss
auf jeden Fall runter einmal Control Blocks machen. In der Gruppe. Äh, ich hab, ich hab
schon mal gesehen, wie Leute das in der Gruppe machen. Das ist mega Big Brain. Die, ähm,
leveln und einer macht, also einer macht Main Quest, die anderen leveln und wenn dann
wichtige Punkte kommen, machen die Portale auf. Ist eigentlich richtig Big Brain gelöst.
Was unter einer Stunde Akt 10. So schnell kannst du nicht mal die NPCs anklicken, die
der alle anklicken musste. So, das hier mache ich nur für Skill Points. Irgendwo hier unten
müsste es was geben. Muss ich einsammeln für Skill Points? Ah, ne, ne, ne, nicht einsammeln
fürs, Boss, einen Boss muss ich killen für Skill Points. So war es. Wenn ich jetzt noch
finde, wo der Boss ist. Vielleicht links rum. Kann ich soweit sein. Da.
Das ist der Boss, der so nervig rumfliegt. Ja. Aber eine Stunde, wie machen die das denn?
Da muss jeder quasi zu einem Quest Ort rennen und dann machen sie sich alle Portals auf
gegenseitig oder so. Anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären.
Smoke Mine, Flamendash. Ja, Smoke Mine, Flamendash hat der 330 auch gemacht. Smoke Mine, Flamendash
oder Flamendash oder Dash? Ich glaube, Dash spielen die nur, ne? Auf jeden Fall Smoke
Mine. Da kannst du über die halbe Map springen und vor allem coole, also richtig gute Abkürzungen
verwenden. Na, so wie bei echten Speedruns, ja, klar. Es ist ja ein echter Speedrun. Also,
das ist das Speed, eines der speedrunnigsten Games, in denen du Speedrunnen kannst, wenn
man es mal so sieht. So eine Sache muss ich doch jetzt noch machen.
Eine Sache muss ich hier doch jetzt noch machen für Points. Ich rush hier einfach mal schnell
durch. Ne, hier muss ich nix mal machen, ne? Ne, ne. Gabs Passive Exide schon bei Awesome
Games? Gute Frage, müsste man mal suchen danach, weiß ich nicht. Wenn nicht, sollte
es das geben. Das ist auch, das ist speedrunnmäßig auch übelst nice zu schauen. Wir können uns
das nächste Sonntag angucken. Den eine Stunde Group World Record da. Ne, hier geht's später
erst lang. Ach so. Ah, hier, hier geht's weiter. Ich muss ja mal gucken, ob ich nicht irgendwas
vergessen hab. Nope, oh, jetzt lang. Ach ne, genau, ne, ich bin hier richtig. Genau,
das muss ich jetzt noch machen. Spellslinger macht so unglaublich Bock zu leveln. Das könnte
ich den ganzen Tag machen. So nice. So, hier muss ich gar nicht teleporten, hier kann ich
einfach zurückrennen. Ja, Havoc hab ich auch schon ein paar Runs geguckt. Havoc, Taitai,
Killer und noch irgendeinem. Man lernt, man lernt auch richtig viel über das Game, wenn
man Speedruns guckt. Moment, ich bin grad ein bisschen verwirrt. Wo muss ich noch mal
hin? Er kann ja nicht mal viele Möglichkeiten geben. Ja, da muss ich rein. So, jetzt muss
ich noch mal den gleichen Boss killen, wie von Akt 5, weil wir gerne Bosse recyceln.
Hoffentlich finde ich schnell den Ausgang. Was auch cool ist, wo man teilweise mit Smoke
mal drüberspringen kann. Und man kann sich dort richtig gute, also, ich sag mal so, wenn
die Builds schnell sind für die Pros, dann sind das meistens auch ganz brauchbare Level
Builds für Noobs wie mich. Zum Beispiel der 330 Weltrekord, weiß ich, ob es immer noch
Weltrekord ist, der hat auch Chaos Spellslinger gespielt. Und man sieht ja, das geht gut.
Ja, ich finde auch, man hätte Recycling schlechter machen können. Ich meine, es ist schon ein
bisschen komisch, dass dieser eine komische Bosse da 5x am Start ist, aber die sind meist
da im recyceln. Letztendlich ist ja das ganze Map, das ganze Map Endgame auch, ich vermute
mal zumindest auch nur aus Recycling-Kunden ursprünglich mit entstanden, weil man einfach
die Sachen übernehmen konnte. Und im Nachhinein ist es halt jetzt eigentlich eines der besten
Endgame-Mechaniken, was es sich so gibt. Können wir mal verrecken jetzt? Wow, wow, wow, wow,
wow. So, wo ist der Ausgang? Weiß man mittlerweile, was mit Doctor Disrespect passiert ist in
Nop? Seine Sicht der Dinge ist immer noch, Twitch hat ihm nicht mitgeteilt, warum er
gebannt ist. Ich persönlich kann mir das nicht vorstellen, dass er keine Ahnung hat, warum
er gebannt ist, quasi als einer der größten Twitch-Streamer, als Exclusive-Vertrags-Dings-Twitch-Mensch,
das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass er es nicht weiß oder nicht zumindest eine sehr,
sehr starke Ahnung hat, woran es liegen könnte. Also das glaube ich, das kaufe ich ihm nicht
ab, dass er gar keine Ahnung hat. Allerdings, eins muss man auch mal sagen, dadurch, dass
Twitch so Secret macht, sorgt es nicht unbedingt für großartige Glaubwürdigkeit, weil umso
geheimnisvoller du alles machst, umso mehr shady wirkt im Endeffekt alles, was du machst.
Also du kannst die logischsten Beweggründe haben, wenn du halt so Secret agierst, dann
werden die Leute immer misstrauischer. Und dann auch bei Sachen, die superbegründet
logisch sind, sagen sie dann, ob das so die ganze Wahrheit ist. Also wenn du so, die Leute
denken halt, du machst so shady, krumme Sachen und deswegen erklärst du es nicht. Ich verstehe
auch nicht, ganz ehrlich, ich verstehe auch überhaupt nicht, wo das Problem ist, weil
so weiß doch mittlerweile keiner mehr, wie man die Toss richtig auslegen muss. Wenn einmal
in den Toss was drinnen steht und mal nichts passiert, mal steht in den Toss was drinnen,
die Leute verschwinden quasi, die Accounts fliegen heimlich weg, man weiß nicht auf
Grundlage von was. Also das macht, also großartiges Vertrauen schafft das nicht, muss ich ehrlich
sagen. Also Kommunikation ist das a und ober sowas. Wo ist denn der komische Boss jetzt?
Please. Game. Wo ist der Boss? Das ist das letzte was ich mache. Ah da, hier.
So, Boss Recycling, exzellent. Au. Fax dann, wann macht er überhaupt Damage? Der hat noch
nie Damage gemacht. Warum darf der auf einmal Damage machen? So, da sind wir durch, da
haben wir es. Jetzt noch Boss killen und gut ist. Noch ein paar Skillbox abholen. Au,
das ist nicht schlecht. Da kann man mal eine gebrauchen für. Ah, keine Ahnung. Mag das
was? Nope. Das ist ja Ultra Crap. Hey, das ist nicht übel. Machen wir mal so, halten
wir vielleicht ein bisschen mehr aus. So, und den Kram hier abholen. Skillbook, jop.
So, Passives, mal gucken ob wir alles haben. 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 21, ein Passive kriege
ich am Ende noch und dann ist die Kampagne durch. 2 kriege ich am Ende noch, 2, 2 kriege
ich am Ende noch. Äh, Moment. Ich bin falsch. Ich bin falsch. Ich muss dahin. Wir sind
ja nicht in Akt 5, wir sind in Akt 10. Ich muss dahin die Wand aufsprengen lassen. Oh,
ich brenne. So, letzten 2, ich habe 11 Skillpunkte. Holy shit. Wo mache ich die denn hin? Äh,
kurz, kurz lurken. Ja, genau Katz, da guckste. Ähm, ja. Wo können wir noch was hinpacken?
Ah, hier unten, hier unten. Live, live, excellent, excellent, live, live können wir nicht genug
haben und in der Runde Chaos Resist können wir noch reinhauen. Chaos Resist kann man nicht
genug haben. Chaos, Chaos, Chaos und Chaos Over Time, jawoll, volle Pulle. Ach, das haben
wir schon. Das haben wir schon. Haben wir hier unten noch schönes Area, äh, Area of Effect.
Brauchen wir immer, immer wieder. Komm her. Das habe ich auch schon. Fack. Habe ich das
alles schon geskillt. Ähm, ja, dann gehen wir jetzt hier rüber. Zack, zack. Wisdom,
intelligence. Dann gehen wir jetzt hier rüber. Äh, und dann? Hoch zu Area. Dann, ja. Bist
sonst irgendwas übersehen? Nee, oder? Ah, hier. Was ist das? Cast Speed while holding
a shield? Okay, dann machen wir das erstmal. Das klingt, das klingt, äh, fack. Klingt
big brain. Haben wir hier den mal. Oh ja, mehr Spell Damage. Spell Damage beste. Kann
man nicht, kann man nicht verkehrt machen. Und Shield haben wir ja am Start. Gut, dann
sind wir perfekt gewappnet für den letzten Fight. Auf geht's. Der Build zackt. Das ist
absolut nicht optimiert. Ich habe das erst beste, das erst beste Chaos Spellslinger genommen
war. Okay, ich weiß nicht, ob er zackt, ehrlich gesagt. Ich hab's mir nicht näher angeguckt.
Das ist ja auch nur zum Level, danach wird eh Respekt. Hier volle Pulle durch. Ähm,
wir sollten noch das Lab vorher machen, ha? Wir sollten noch, wir sollten noch das Lab
vorher, wobei. Wo der Schaden herkommt, äh, das ist Dot. Das ist einfach nur krasser
Dot Damage zum größten Teil. Ich glaube, ich mach das Lab vorher noch. Also das macht
AE Damage, dann gibt's hier diese Essence Strain. Geschichte, das ist das, wo hab ich
es hier allerdings? Äh ne, das ist Soulrend. Wo hab ich mein Essence Strain? So, 4. Es
ist übrigens Mist, das stimmt gar nicht, weil es erzählt. Ähm, Soulrend ist das,
was da raus, raus spreadet und noch Damage macht. Das macht im Prinzip alles wahnsinnig
viel Dot Damage. Und ich hab halt mit einer Attacke 3 Sachen, inklusive Curse. Weil ich
hab hier noch Curse on Hit drin. Irgendwo. Genau. Und wenn ich quasi mit Frenzy den Gegner
treffe, kriegt er noch nen Debuff. Frenzy ist das Grüne. Ne, für Bosse ist es nicht
so geil. Ja, das machen wir jetzt noch. Activate. Bosse Lab. Für Bosse ist es nicht so geil.
Wobei, man könnte das auch ganz brauchbar für Bosse machen, indem man noch ein bisschen
äh, weitere Debuffs mit rein nimmt. Wie der Typ hier übrigens auch vor, äh, auch vor
schlägt. Weil, äh, ich hab's bloß nicht gemacht. Also der schlägt hier noch vor,
oh Mist. Der schlägt vor, man soll noch, ja, ähm, das Whizzer mit rein nehmen. Was auch
immer. Hab ich mir jetzt nicht die Mühe gemacht, weil ich komm easy so durch. Moment, wo geht's
lang? Äh, PoE Lab. Ich muss das Lab aufmachen. Äh, PoE Lab. PoE Lab. PoE Lab. Jetzt sind
wir im Merciless Lab. Okay, es ist im Prinzip egal. Was ist Argus? Singen Boss? Was ist
Argus? Also gehen wir oben lang. Alter, PoE, please, da war doch eben gar nix. Da war doch
gar nix. Ich hab da extra reingeguckt. Keg W. Da reicht Keg W schon nicht mehr. Okay,
wo ist denn jetzt hier der Schlüssel? Muss ja erst mal einen Schlüssel suchen. Moment,
ist der Schlüssel, die Schlüssellocation da auch drauf? Nee, ne? Schlüssellocation
ist da nicht drauf. Kauft ihr euch eigentlich noch Filme? Ja, also jetzt so klassische Sachen
mit Blu-Ray und so. Nein, nur noch Streaming. Nur noch Streaming. Ey, Max, ich wollte es...
was? Mensch, ich muss kurz aufpassen, dass ich nicht verrecke, weil sonst muss ich wieder
von vorne anfangen hier. Ey, Max, ich wollte mal fragen, wie ist mit Arbeitsstunden in
der IT? War am Freitag bis 22... Nein, das ist definitiv nicht normal. Bis 22 Uhr, nein,
das ist nicht normal. Gerade Freitags bin ich sogar eher ein bisschen früher draußen.
Man muss halt sagen, das hat nichts mit IT zu tun. Schlechte Firmen, die entweder total
unkoordiniert sind oder ihre Leute ausbeuten, mag es überall geben. Ich kann jetzt natürlich
nicht sagen, ob das bei dir der Fall ist. Wenn es Ausnahmen gibt, kann das durchaus
sein, dass in Einzelfällen mal gerechtfertigt ist. Aber ohne, dass man euch erklärt, warum,
tut sich das nicht in Ordnung. Und es ist auch nicht normal und es sollte auch nicht
normal sein. Oder was war denn der Grund, warum du so lange da bleiben musstest? Du
musst ja irgendwas gegeben haben. Ich meine, wenn die Live-Umgebung gerade am Abscheißen
ist, würde ich auch nicht gleich heimgehen. So, Moment, wir mussten jetzt, Sekunde, wir
mussten jetzt hoch. Was? Oh. Ich bin im Lab, ich kann gerade nicht. Kann man eigentlich
im Lab auslocken, auf einen anderen Char locken und wieder rein? Nee, oder? Und Chet, wenn
ihr sagt Ja, glaube ich es euch nicht. Weil der Chachi badet mich dann. Gute Idee. Ich
habe nicht geguckt, wo ich hin muss. Nach oben rechts muss ich. Also wahrscheinlich
gar nicht hier lang, sondern vorne auf der anderen Seite. Ist es jetzt hier oder hier?
Okay. Oh, Säge kommt ja vor wie der mit Copperfield. Ypsin tut eigentlich noch.
So, hier müsste jetzt noch die Tür kommen, klar. Aha. PoE Lab Beste. Also, Moment, ich
wollte gerade mal Chet gucken. Wenn es die Filme nicht bei Prime und Netflix gibt. Naja,
es gibt genug Quellen im Internet, wo man sich das angucken kann, wenn die Hersteller
nicht wollen, dass man Geld ausgibt. Also, Limsy schreibt, bei uns ist es generell ein
gewisser Druck, dass man nicht als Erster gehen möchte. Schlechter Eindruck. Das ist
bescheuert mit dem IT Consulting. Kacke ist das. Arbeit ist nicht dein Leben. Oder Arbeiten
ist nicht das Leben. Man arbeite, dass man leben kann. Das finde ich bescheuert. Arbeitest
du da? Bist du vielleicht sogar Azubi? Wenn du Azubi bist, ist das ein ganz großes Unding,
wenn du da bis 22 Uhr wärst. Als Azubi ist das absolut nicht vertretbar. Ah, ich habe
nicht nachgeguckt, wo es lang geht. Du bist als Praktikant? Nein. Definitiv nicht. Als
Praktikant bis 22 Uhr ist ja ein absolutes Unding. Ey, wir müssen wieder oben rechts.
Ja, stimmt. Okay, wann hast du angefangen? Wenn du mittags um 14 Uhr anfängst, ist ja
wieder was anderes. Muss ich hier durch? Muss ich hier echt durch, durch den Müll? Muss
ich hier oben rechts? 8.30 Uhr? Nein, nein, nein. WTF? 8.30 Uhr? Das sind 14 Stunden.
Nee, absolute Rotzfirma. Was ist das denn? Richtiger Pult. Nee, nee, nee. Das ist,
das ist weder normal, ich halte es sogar für fraglich, ob das überhaupt zulässig ist.
Bin da aber kein Experte, was solche Sachen angeht natürlich. Nein, das ist auf jeden
Fall, das ist weder normal noch ist es okay. Wollen die Leute, wollen die das mal mit 30
Jahren stirbt oder was? So nach dem Motte, jawoll, ich habe 10 Jahre Top Performance
auf der Arbeit geliefert, jetzt kann ich sterben oder was? Wo ist das für eine Logik, Alter?
Nee, nee, nee. Überstunden werden im Übrigen auch nicht bezahlt und als selbstverständlich
angenommen. Das ist ein Riesenindikator für absolute Bullshit Firma, die wahrscheinlich
auch keinen Betriebsrat haben wird oder sowas und sogar eine, die sich eventuell sogar schon
die rechtliche Grauzone, die es da gibt, überschritten hat. Also das ist eine Firma, da würde ich
vielleicht mein Praktikum noch machen, aber im Leben nicht arbeiten. Und gerade wenn du
Praktikant bist, ich habe schon wieder nicht gekauft, gerade wenn du Praktikant bist, musst
du dich ja da auch nicht in irgendeiner Art und Weise verpflichtet fühlen.
Es kommt, letztendlich kommt es aber immer ein bisschen auf die Umstände an, also man
kann die meisten Sachen nicht so pauschal, fuck, wo waren wir denn jetzt? Da oben rechts,
da wieder oben rechts. Also man kann, wie alles, nicht immer pauschal sagen, dass das niemals
so sein kann. Also zum Beispiel bei uns, wenn es irgendwie Umschaltungen im Rechenzentrum
gibt oder so, da war ich auch schon über Nacht da, allerdings dann erst um 19 Uhr,
by the way, ob geht es hier nicht lang, aber so sieht es ja so aus, als, und das gab ja
auch dementsprechend einen Ausgleich, sowohl Geld als auch Freizeit mäßig, aber da sieht
es ja so aus, als lassen sie die Leute im Endeffekt schuften, ohne auch noch mehr Wert
irgendwie zu bieten. Ist da ein Startup? Ja, gerade da muss man ein bisschen aufpassen.
Ich muss sagen, ich persönlich habe noch nie bei einem Startup gearbeitet, sofern man
diesen, nein dieser Provider, wo ich gearbeitet habe, das war kein Startup mehr, die sind
ganz besonders gut drin, so nach dem Motto, wir geben drei Jahre übelst Gas und verkaufen
den Laden dann, aber du darfst nicht vergessen, du hast keinerlei Verpflichtung diesem Laden
gegenüber, außer das, was du unterschrieben hast in deinem Arbeitsvertrag, ansonsten hast
du denen auch keine moralische irgendwie Verpflichtung oder so. Erfüll deinen Arbeitsvertrag und
gut ist. Ich würde jetzt da nicht instant auf Stress machen gehen, ja, weil du willst
ja deine Praktikumszeit da möglichst angenehm, so angenehm wie möglich verbringen, wenn
du da gleich Stress machst, ist das wahrscheinlich nicht mehr möglich, aber ich würde mich
diesem Laden nicht verpflichtet fühlen, in irgendeiner Art und Weise da mehr zu machen
und von irgendwie, wenn einer ankommt, so, das macht einen schlechten Eindruck, das andere
macht auch einen schlechten Eindruck bei dir, ein sowas finde ich ist ein absolutes Unding
und gerade Startups machen so auf die Taktik, so nach dem Motto, lass mal die Leute maximal
ausbeuten, damit wir den Laden nach drei Jahren verkaufen können und du hast ja davon
nichts hättest du jetzt, hättest du jetzt Anteil, also mal angenommen, ja, du wärst
bei einem Startup dabei und hättest irgendwie Anteile und du würdest sagen, okay, ich arbeite
mir fünf Jahre den Hintern wund, dass ich dann Millionär bin, wenn das Startup gut
verkauft wird, okay, das ist eine Sache, das könnte ich nachvollziehen, wenn man so jemand
ist, das könnte ich verstehen, wenn das jemand macht, aber hast du ja in dem Fall gar nicht,
du bist den weder als verpflichtet, noch, also vertraglich schon mal gar nicht, noch hast
du was davon, das ist ja doppelt Lull im Endeffekt, doppelt plus Lull, cack triple you Lull, Lull
W, aber ey, wo muss ich denn wieder rechts hoch, ne, ja, wäre das jetzt wie sagen wir
bei Facebook gewesen, wo die Leute sich den Arschhund gearbeitet haben, an die Börse
gegangen sind, sie waren über Nacht Millionär, okay, hey, das war was anderes, aber die haben
sich das, die haben sich das, oh fuck, Alter, muss mal kurz konzentrieren, die haben sich
auch freiwillig für entschieden, nein, nein, nein, ah, Monka, ich hatte keine Flasks,
oh nix, nicht laufen, wenn du blutest, ja, musst da dran denken, ich denk da nicht dran,
weil ich hab, ah, Switch, ich hab halt so ne Anti-Pleet-Geschichte bei mir, bester Raum,
was ist das hier jetzt gewesen, hab ich noch nie gefunden, sowas, ey, ja, kein Problem,
mich würd mal interessieren, ich weiß nicht, ob du öfters, ob du öfters hier am Start
bist, ich hab dich noch nicht so oft gesehen, mich würd's mal interessieren, wie sich das
entwickelt, ja, was da, was da in Zukunft noch rauskommt, Moment Max, zurück, gucken,
wo's lang geht, wir sind jetzt da, wieder mal oben rechts, alles klar, aber ich kann
dir sagen, das ist definitiv nicht normal, oh ne, die explodier Typen, aha, easy, äh,
nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, da wollte ich grad nicht lang, äh, wait a minute, ah,
ich will eins weiter, ich will eins weiter oben, hab mich verguckt, nächste, nächste
Ausgang will ich, da, den hier, ah, Mist, hier geht's nicht durch, fu, aber hier geht's
hoffentlich durch, jawoll, so, Isarobaschen, übrigens, das letzte Lab ist ein bisschen
schwieriger, da gibt's noch Fallen beim Endboss, da bin ich auch schon mal richtig dumm verreckt,
so, das ist auch noch so ein dummes Layout, nein, nein, nein, nein, okay, Monka, Monka
Giga, was haben wir hier, Bone Ullos, die, ähm, hab ich letzte, letzte League für
mein Neko gebraucht, vorletzte, vorletzte League, hab ich nen Schlüssel vergessen,
zwei, okay, wollt grad sagen zwei, hab ich irgendwas zum enchanten, nope, wirklich, so,
äh, und jetzt brauchen wir, ich glaub, das da, was, was, was nehmen wir jetzt, muss ich
mal kurz, kurz überlegen, Increase Skill Effect Duration, Reduce Damage Tank Damage
or Increase Poison Duration, More Damage Overtime, also mehr Damage, mehr Damage ist immer gut
und Cast Speed, und das hier bringt was, Evasion, Energy Shield, Attack Speed, Cast Speed, Evasion
Rating Pair, okay, Defense brauch ich erstmal nicht, mehr Damage, Defense mach ich dann
als nächstes, äh, Bumba Ding Bum Bum Bum Bum, wie auch immer, genau, schreibt grade im Chat,
also zwei Kollegen aus einem anderen Team haben während der Kurzarbeit jeweils knapp
80 Überstunden gemacht, weil sinnfreie Versprechungen vom Chef nicht einbehalten werden, haben am
Ende nichts dafür bekommen, weil ist ja verboten, äh, das ist dann sowas, wo ich denke, da kann
man seinen Chef auch mal damit konfrontieren und fragen, wie siehts da aus, was ist, was
ist hier, was ist hier Sache, ne, es muss ja immer auf letztendlich beidseitigem, was
man das Vertrauen nennen sollte, beidseitigem, äh, Einverständnis beruhen, was da passiert,
ja, du kannst nicht, du kannst nicht erwarten, dass die Leute alles machen, also, ne, also
man kann aus der Sicht der Firma nicht erwarten, dass die Leute alles machen und, äh, nichts
dafür bekommen, im Umkehrschluss kann man auch nicht erwarten, dass die Firma wahnsinnig
unwirtschaftliche, unsinnige Dinge für einmacht, letztendlich glaube ich, ist das Beste, wenn
man auf diesen ganzen Bullshit-Talk, den in vielen Firmen gemacht wird, grade in Start-ups
und grade in der IT gemacht wird, so nach dem Motto, wir sind alle Familie, wir sind
alle Freunde und wir sind alle furchtbar dicke und so, wenn man da einfach nichts drauf
gibt und es mal nüchtern sieht, wie es ist, man ist da, um Geld zu verdienen und das einzige,
woran man sich halten muss, beide Seiten halten müssen, ist den Vertrag, den man unterschrieben
hat, das heißt, ich mach das, wofür ich da bin, wofür die mich gekauft haben, wofür
die mich bezahlen und die haben mich gefälligt, auch dafür zu bezahlen, wenn nicht, bin ich
ja quasi, äh, was heißt das auf deutsch, volunteer, ähm, was heißt volunteer auf deutsch,
halt freiwilliger, ha, und wenn ich freiwilliger bin, da muss ich keinen Arbeitsvertrag unterschreiben.
Das sollen sich alle Seiten mal drauf besinnen und letztendlich ist doch, ist doch den Unternehmen
auch klar, dass die Leute da arbeiten, weil sie Geld verdienen müssen, die arbeiten da
doch nicht, weil sie die besten auf der Welt sind und sie sich noch quasi seit ihrer Kindheit
nichts sehnlicher gewünscht haben, als dort zu arbeiten, das, das ist auch, ähm, Punkt,
äh, Schneeflockchen, das sag ich auch immer, ähm, wenn es so nach dem geht, wenn irgendwie
wieder einer anfängt, so, wir sind alles eine Familie, ich find's gut, dass die Familie
sagen und nicht Freunde, weil Freunde kannst du dir aussuchen, Familie nicht, so ähnlich
ist es auf der Arbeit, ja, wenn du da irgendwelche Leute hast, das kannst du dir nicht aussuchen,
ja, aber spätestens, wenn das dauerhaft einseitig ist, ähm, hat das, hat das auch keinen Sinn,
ich hab keine Probleme auf der Arbeit den Leuten da ein bisschen, beziehungsweise der Firma
ein bisschen entgegenzukommen, solange der Rest passt und ich halt irgendwie auch was
davon habe, ja, aber wenn es immer nur so rum ist, dass ich permanent was machen soll,
also, dass, dass, dass die eine Seite immer nur was bekommt und nichts abgibt, das ist,
das ist wie, keine Ahnung, das ist, das ist wie in irgendeiner Beziehung oder so, es ist
auch komplett sinnlos, wenn einer sich von morgens bis abends Mühe gibt und sich permanent
was aus den Fingern saugen sollte, muss, um den anderen so entertain zu halten, ist auch
Schwachsinn, das muss auch beidseitig irgendwie funktionieren und so kann es auch nicht sein,
dass du, dass, dass die eine Seite dort auf der Arbeit quasi alles machen soll und nichts
dafür bekommt, ja, das einzige, wo sich beide dran halten müssen ist der Arbeitsvertrag
und wenn man eben wiederholt mehr leistet als im Arbeitsvertrag steht und sich in keinster
Weise erkenntlich gezeigt wird, sodass man damit zufrieden ist auf Dauer, ja, dann macht
man halt einfach nicht die Sachen mehr, die nicht im Arbeitsvertrag stehen und dann kann
sich beim besten Willen keiner beschweren drüber, genau, wenn es für mehr mehr gibt und man
damit zufrieden ist, vollkommen okay, aber man kann nicht sagen, oh heute ist wichtig,
heute musst du mehr machen, aber nichts dafür bekommen, das ist, knackt, warum sollte man
das machen, gerade in der IT ist es ja nun wirklich nicht so, als ist man da irgendwie,
als gibt es da keine Jobs oder so, also bei uns gibt es keine Überstunden, doch, stimmt,
nein, stimmt so nicht, natürlich gibt es bei uns Überstunden, allerdings, es ist Zeiterfassung
und by the way, es ist mittlerweile glaube ich sogar Pflicht zur Zeiterfassung, bei uns
ist Zeiterfassung und wenn du über 20 oder 30 Überstunden hast, ruf die Personalabteilung
bei deinem Chef an, oh fuck, jetzt habe ich auf den Chat geguckt, ruf die Personalabteilung
bei deinem Chef an und fragt, was da los ist, warum du bei 35 Stunden stehst, was die auch
irgendwo machen müssen, weil die haben ja auch rechtliche Vorgaben, nur, dass die in
irgendwelchen Startups dann halt oft drauf, sie denken so nach, ja, kriegt doch eh keiner
mit, alter, macht man nicht so viel Damage, man darf sich nicht ausbeuten lassen, ja,
das sehe ich auch so, man kann durchaus Sachen machen, die über den normalen Rahmen rausgehen,
wenn man halt merkt, dass es eben beidseitig passt, ja, wenn man dafür, das Mindeste ist
bezahlt werden, ja, zusätzlich Freizeitausgleich, wie auch immer, wenn man halt sieht, okay,
man ist mit den Bedingungen für diese Mehrleistung einverstanden und zufrieden, what the fuck,
Alter, was macht der für'n Damage, dann ist okay, da kann man auch mehr machen, so, jetzt
ist RIP, so, Boss down, Kampagne durchgespielt, Hyper S, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay,
ja, Schneeflock sehe ich, sehe ich genauso, er schreibt, ein gutes Unternehmen sollte
ja wohl auch Interesse haben, dass eine gute Stimmung herrscht und im Hintergrund nicht
gelässert wird mit, ja, korrekt, es ist ja auch nicht einfach, irgendwie was ausgedacht
ist, sondern es ist erwiesen, dass Leute bessere Arbeit abliefern, wenn die Umstände besser
sind, also wenn du permanent abgefuckt bist, deine Arbeit lieferst du schlechtere Arbeit
ab, als wenn es dir gefällt, es ist ja auch jetzt irgendwie nix, wo man Big Brain für
sein müsste, um da drauf zu kommen, also bei uns ist es so, wenn man am Wochenende arbeiten
muss, genau, Samstags gibt's, ich kann es nicht misserzählen, aber egal, genau, Samstags
gibt's 1,25 bei uns auch oder 1,5, Sonntags gibt es glaube ich sogar doppelt und an Feiertagen
gibt es auch doppelt, genau, nee, am Samstag gibt es 50%, an Sonntagen und Feiertagen
gibt es 100% mehr, also doppelte und ich glaube, wenn es da noch irgendwelche ganz besonderen
Sachen sind, gibt es noch eine Sonderregelung, also quasi Sonntagnacht an Silvester, so nach
dem Motto, das war ganz übertrieben zu sagen, da gibt es nochmal irgendeine Sonderregelung
für, da gibt es glaube ich sogar noch Freizeitausgleich dazu, also sprich du kriegst es nicht nur
doppelt bezahlt, du kriegst auch noch das als Freizeitausgleich dazu und das sind so
Sachen wo ich sagen muss, hey, wenn man das weiß und damit zufrieden ist, vollkommen
in Ordnung, so, Sister Cassia ist die beste, so Passives hab ich alles, oh, äh, den hab
ich noch nicht eingelöst, ne, exellent, so, ich mach mal schnell ne Tier-1-Map, weil
ich sehen will wie gut Tier-1-Maps mit diesem Build ohne irgendwie großartige Investition
funktionieren, aber was heißt Tier-1, Tier-1 muss ich gar nicht meinen, Tier-1 ist easy
as fuck, ähm, Maps, keine Ahnung, machen wir mal ne, was hat denn hier ne halbwegs gescheites
Layout, Excavation geht glaube ich halbwegs, auch mal ne Tier-4-Map und Sana darf auch
nochmal an den Start kommen, gucken wir mal wie gut das den Maps funktioniert, ich mein,
es ist einfach, einfach gelevelled ohne irgendwas, also da ist gar nichts, ja, also, guck mal
da ist gleich Sana am Start, ok, funktioniert genauso easy wie in der Kampagne, sogar besser
als in der Kampagne, Monster Reflect Physical Damage, äh, Reflect, kann ich Reflect Physical,
ne, Reflect Physical kann ich doch nicht machen, weil mein Spellslinger noch nicht Max Level
ist, dann, danach kann ich Reflect Physical machen, Boss, Find Unique Item, excellent.
Also, für Low-Tier-Maps ist das, oh, geht das auch ganz gut durch, nur, dass ich halt
nix aushalte, aber das war ja vorher in der Kampagne auch schon so, äh, die Seeds muss
ich ja nicht sammeln, die sind noch zu low, ich mein, es ist nicht das Bild, was ich hier
spielen werde im Endeffekt, aber, man muss sagen, also, das ist ja nahezu Null Invest
fürs Leveln, das ist reines Level Gear und dafür zerstört es echt schon heftig.
Kann man sich nicht beschweren, kein Wunder, dass der Speedrun Weltrekord ein ähnliches
Bild hatte.
Der Crows Cycle, den brauch ich nicht, der ist eh schon ausgewachsen.
Easy as fuck ist das, guck mal, das ist ein Lull, easy as a fuck, eh, easy as a fuck,
guckt euch mal an, wie das Level abgeht, nein, den Boss machen wir gar nicht, damit fangen
wir uns gar nicht an, irgendwelche Bosse zu machen hier, Boss overrated, clear speed,
activated, accelerated, ist dein Leben nicht mega niedrig, doch, deswegen bin ich auch
instant down, wenn ich mal nicht aufpasse, wie gesagt, ich hab ja nichts im Endeffekt
da, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind, ey, ich hab ja auch absolut Crap Level Gear an, wollen
wir mal gucken, wie gut man hier durchkommt, aber die eins Maps sind eigentlich, also nicht
die eins Maps, die weißen Maps sind eigentlich allesamt mit nahezu noch so Fail Gear Build
drinnen, okay, ich weiß nicht, wo hier noch Monster sein sollen, keine Ahnung, aber hier
nicht mehr, what the fuck, hat er mich gerade gekillt, hat er mich gerade gekillt und ich
bin rausgefacet und ich war wieder voll, lull, hat jemand eine Empfehlung für einen Rekmount
Switch unter 150 Euro, eh, ja, du bist da mit Mikro Tick schon genau richtig, den wünsche
ich dir auch empfehlen, Bastion, alter Bastion, der Spin Slay, den würd ich dir, ich sag dir
gleich welchen, ich guck mal, die haben nämlich ein paar neue, aber den, den du schreibst,
ist glaube ich, den, den ich dir auch empfehlen würde, wir müssen schnell die Map fertig
machen, gucken, wie gut es läuft hier, aber ich mein, das ist ein wirklich richtig geiles,
also Chaos Spellsink ist wirklich ein richtig nicees Build, mit Leveling Gear und, und absolut
kompletten Low Invest Gedöns, rushst du hier durch wie sonst was, okay, ich brauch ein
bisschen mehr Leben, ja, ich weiß, aber das ist ja easy zu fixen, allein schon an meiner
Crafting Bench kann ich da ein bisschen was draufhauen, so, aber wie gesagt, ich speck
eh um, ich speck eh um, also, wieviel hab ich eigentlich, Respec Points, 12 Refund Points,
oh, was, ich weiß gar nicht, wieviel ich brauche, oh, guck mal, ein Blight Encounter, mal gucken,
wie der läuft, manche viel los hier, oh, Ice, Stun, von unten kommt auch noch was, oh fuck,
oh, da mach ich zu wenig Damage für, oh, da mach ich zu wenig Damage für, fuck, shit,
da mach ich nicht genug Damage für, oh, es wird knapp, das wird knapp, oh, okay, wir
haben es doch noch gepackt, das war aber auch wirklich knapp, guck mal, ob in den Kisten
was gescheites ist, oh, gut aushalten durch, null, oh, wir haben auch so einen Legion Encounter,
es meint es gut mit uns hier, die Map, Sana drauf, Legion Encounter, Blight, nice, oh,
die machen mir zu, oh, die machen mir zu viel Damage da oben, MonkaS, hör auf Damage zu
machen, ich habe nicht genug Leben, okay, da tropfen 1000 Dinger, ah, der Müll, das
Ding wird gesellt, aber für den absolut null Invest Build ist das, das ist top, ich meine,
das ist ultra spaßig zu leveln, du killst damit in der Kampagne alles easy as fuck und
für Anfang Maps ist es auch gut, also wenn die es nicht total nerven, werde ich nächste
League damit starten, aber es kann durchaus sein, dass sie es nerven, aber ich hoffe nicht,
Max Alter Metaslave, ist so, so, jetzt wollen wir nochmal Metamorph, aber da verrecken wir
jetzt wahrscheinlich, ach, das geht, das wusste ich gar nicht, dass man auch hier drauf klicken
kann, null, das lerne ich jetzt, dachte ich immer, man muss hier klicken, keck, W, dreifach
W, okay, den mache ich ganz gut Damage, ach, ich habe auch vergessen, übrigens Leben einzustellen,
ich muss Monster, Boss, Boss Monster, Boss Monster Leben anzeigen, wo war das denn nochmal?
Ach, und Alice brauche ich es nicht, nice, sehr schön, so, gut, excellent, Leute, wir
haben es geschafft, Kampagne durch, hey, das brauche ich für mein Ice Nova Build, äh,
das brauche ich für mein Ice Nova Build, oder was, oder was, ja, nicer Drop, aber 5 Chaos
gespart, hat auf jeden Fall immer aus genauer Kostet, 10 Chaos oder so gespart, okay, Crap,
Crap, Crap, Crap, hat es doch schonmal gelohnt, was ist das, auch Crap, äh, wo habe ich denn
meine Waffe dafür, wo habe ich denn das versteckt, äh, alter, meine Ordnung, ja, ah, hier, okay,
da finde ich es auch garantiert wieder, so, wunderbar, Chat, cute Chat, schön, dass ihr
dabei wart, ich gehe jetzt was futtern, ich habe übelst Hunger, ey, ich war jetzt irgendwie
10 Stunden oder so on heute, solange war ich ja schon ewig nicht mehr on, was zu machen,
wie, guck mal, wie lange war ich heute on, ja, ja, Max ist gut, ja, näher fast, neuneinhalb
Stunden auf WTF, ach ne, Mikrotik-Router, Felix bist noch da, wollte ich ja noch gucken, also,
ähm, Switch, genau, welchen Switch würde ich dir empfehlen, und zwar, ich glaube das ist
übrigens der richtige, den du daraus, ja, exakt, ja, genau den würde ich dir empfehlen,
es gibt kaum einen Switch mit besserem Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis und zwei 10G Ports als den, die CRS-Variante
ist übrigens, äh, exakt das gleiche, nur dass du Router OS drauf installieren kannst,
also wenn du wirklich einen Switch brauchst und damit auch keine Sperenzien machen willst,
einfach nur einen Switch haben willst, lohnen sich die 50 Euro Aufpreis gar nicht, also
du hast dir genau das richtige rausgesucht, den würde ich mir auch kaufen in dem Preissegment,
ist der beste, den es gibt, das nächste, was nicht schlecht ist, wenn man nur 10G braucht,
ist der hier, der ist auch ziemlich gut, also für 150 Euro, äh, vier, äh, SFP plus Ports,
aber du brauchst wahrscheinlich auch die 24 Gigabit Ports, denke ich mal, ne, du willst
wahrscheinlich nicht nur 10G anschließen, bester Switch, den du dir da verkaufen kannst,
ja, so sieht es aus, gut toll, schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid, Massive, ich bin schon
ganz, ganz, äh, fertig im Hirn, ja, ich geh jetzt was futtern und wir sehen uns, bis
dann, zum nächsten Stream, morgen, wieder ein bisschen Linux und Raspberry Pi Zeug, Technik
Kram, wir sehen uns, machts gut, bis dann, C U.